français mais ils répondront à nos
questions et ce seront bien les
représentants des différents groupes
politiques qui donneront leur opinion
sur la guerre en ukraine voilà ses
représentants politiques qui seront au
micro de compte un calme est au sénat et
d'elsa monde un gamin à l'assemblée et
sur ce plateau pour débattre de cette
allocution de volodymyr et l'inscrit nos
invités nicolas tenzer bonjour vous êtes
directeur de la publication de desk
russie et spécialiste des questions
internationales merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation a ni daubenton bonjour
je vous êtes journaliste spécialiste de
l'ukraine vous êtes également ancienne
conseillère culturelle à l'ambassade de
france à kiev et auteur de l'ukraine
l'indépendance à tout prix et puis
j'avais également sur ce plateau ronan
le gleut bonjour vous êtes sénateur
républicain dea français établis hors de
france et puis dans quelques secondes on
accueillera également votre collègue
jean yves le conte on va prendre tout de
suite à la direction de la salle des
conférences du sénat retrouver quand un
call mais quand un bon jour alors
comment elle va se dérouler cet
événement au sénat eh bien volodymyr
zelensky va prendre la parole en direct
et en visio c'est donc à vivre à partir
de 15h un message diffusé donc en direct
et en simultané dans les deux chambres
du parlement
un événement donc historique ne serait
ce que par sa forme avec ce message d'un
président étranger c'est une première
diffusé dans l'enceinte de l'hémicycle
pour l'occasion d'ailleurs au sénat un
drapeau ukrainien a été disposé avec
celui de la france et l'union européenne
sur le plateau de la tribune et des
rubans de petits rubans bleus et jaunes
ont été distribués aux sénateurs pour
qu'ils puissent les porter dans
l'hémicycle on attend d'ailleurs trois
invités de marque dans la tribune
présidentielle
au sénat il s'agit de dignitaires de
l'ambassade d'ukraine à paris ou de la
commission européenne en france une
séance exceptionnelle puisque la séance
publique élevée depuis fin février mais
l'occasion pour les deux chambres du
parlement d'afficher une forme d'union
nationale et d'exprimer une nouvelle
fois je cite la solidarité de la france
au peuple ukrainien c'est ce qu'a dit
gérard larcher il ya quelques jours
merci quand un calme et on part tout de
suite à l'assemblée nationale salle des
quatre colonnes où se trouve l âme
dingue à 20 richard ferrand va donc
prendre la parole après gérard lâcher
elsa cette intervention est quand même
un tout petit peu particulière au
palais-bourbon car elle va être suivi
par de nombreux députés dont certains
sont candidats à l'élection
présidentielle
oui puisque comptant voulait dit
normalement les travaux sont suspendus
le temps de la campagne présidentielle
est bien de très nombreux députés sont
revenus à l'assemblée pour assister à
cette intervention du président est
chrétien et parmi ces députés il ya des
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
marine le pen pour le rassemblement
national jean luc mélenchon pour la
france insoumise nicolas dupont aignan
fabien roussel pour le parti communiste
s'est lui excusé pour des raisons
familiales façon de dire évidemment il
ya un moment d'union nationale mais il
ya quand même une campagne
présidentielle qui continuent alors le
président ukrainien ils utilisent cette
arme diplomatique un ces adresses à
différents parlements du monde entier et
à chaque fois il personnalise son
message 1 devant le parlement
britannique il a cité churchill il a
cité shakespeare devant le congrès
américain il a parlé de pearl harbor ou
encore du 11 septembre et du mur de
berlin devant le bundestag allemand ici
à l'assemblée nationale et au sénat il
va donc a priori faire des références à
l'histoire de france pour demander donc
le soutien des parlementaires merci
beaucoup elle a alors effectivement
volodymyr zelensky s'est exprimé déjà
devant les parlements de plusieurs
puissances occidentales
on va voir quelles sont les attentes du
président ukrainien vis-à-vis de
l'occident à les explications de nicolas
fleury
presque un mois après le début de
l'invasion russe le président ukrainien
va s'adresser aux parlementaires
français un discours en direct de kiev
pour demander la solidarité de la france
et des sanctions plus fortes contre la
russie le tout dans la lignée de son
discours devant le parlement européen
fermer leur tous vos ports ne leur
envoyais pas vos marchandises refuser
les ressources énergétiques fait
pression pour que la russie kit
l'ukraine
et albi la suite d'une tournée entamée
devant les parlementaires occidentaux
avec à chaque fois un message sur mesure
comme hier face aux députés italiens mon
image ici pour ceux qui ont lancé cette
guerre l'italie est un lieu de vacances
alors ne soyez pas un lieu de
villégiature pour les meurtriers bloquer
tous leurs biens immobiliers
face au congrès américain le président
hélène ce qui n'a pas hésité à invoquer
l'histoire des états unis
[Applaudissements]
souvenez-vous de pearl harbor quand
votre ciel était assombrie par les
avions qui vous attaquent et
aujourd'hui j'ai la nécessité de
protéger notre ciel j'ai besoin de votre
aide
aujourd'hui le président ukrainien
devrait défendre sa demande d'adhésion à
l'union européenne est appelée à faire
respecter les couloirs humanitaires
quant au soutien militaire volodymyr
zelensky attendra sûrement demain pour
l'évoquer il profitera de la visite de
joe biden en europe pour s'exprimer
devant l'otan
ronan le gleut vous êtes sénateur les
républicains des français établis hors
de france dites-nous vous serez dans
l'hémicycle vous dans moins d'une heure
maintenant pour écouter vos limerzel
inscrit qu'est ce que vous attendez de
cette allocution
c'était extrêmement important en tant
que parlementaires d'être présent pour
cette locution parce que ce qui se joue
c'est tout simplement larchitecture de
sécurité du continent et peut-être même
au-delà c'est l'ordre du monde qui se
joue est par conséquent être présent
c'est très important et vous savez
marine le pen a exprimé le fait que
selon elle n'avait pas d'admiration
particulière pour zelensky et bien je ne
partage pas cette opinion au contraire
j'ai
en tout cas elle a prononcé ces mots une
première fois et bien je tiens à vous
exprimer mon opinion c'est que j'ai de
l'admiration pour le courage du chef
d'état de l'ukraine et c'est la raison
pour laquelle c'était si important à mes
yeux d'être présent aujourd'hui j'en
rêve le compte 1 vous êtes sénateur
socialiste également des français
établis hors de france qu'est ce que
vous attendez de ce discours de volodine
c'est
qu'il essaye de convaincre les français
que la
guerre qui se passe aujourd'hui en
ukraine c'est une guerre pour le droit
pour les valeurs européennes qu'ils sont
attaqués il faut pas passer son temps à
répéter nous ne sommes pas en guerre
nous sommes en guerre
nos valeurs sont en guerre et
aujourd'hui on a d'une certaine manière
sous traitée aux ukrainiens à leur
courage et leur détermination
la défense de ces valeurs et il est
indispensable de convaincre l'ensemble
de
ddd des français qu'il faut être aux
côtés du peuple ukrainien pas simplement
dans l'accueil c'est fantastique ce qui
se passe depuis quelques semaines en
terme d'accueil mais pour les aider
parce que l'avenir du continent dépend
aujourd'hui de 2 2 ce qui se passe en
ukraine la manière dont nous allons
vivre donc nous pourrons être libres
indépendants ou pas dépend de ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui en ukraine et nous
devons être aux côtés des ukrainiens
jusqu'au bout pour défendre ses
principes et j'espère qu'il arrivera à
nous convaincre en tout cas vous avez
bien compris que en ce qui me concerne
je le suis un petit peu d'avancé mais
même si la résistance du peuple
ukrainien est fantastique depuis depuis
un mois maintenant
les l'ensemble des forces qui défendent
les mêmes valeurs doivent être de
manière résolue aux côtés de l'ukraine
année daubenton quels effets peut avoir
ce discours du président alain ce qu'ils
écoutent et je pense qu'il y a deux
aspects bien sûr il ya la france
c'est les droits de l'homme c'est la
liberté c'est la démocratie c'est les
élections libres pour lesquels les
ukrainiens se sont battus depuis 2000 il
faut quand même le rappeler à de
nombreuses reprises avant cette guerre
l'autre point extrêmement important
sûrement encore plus important c'est
l'europe c'est l'europe avec ce que ça
signifie pour pour le pouvoir ukrainien
en termes de d'arrimage aux réformes
dead vous savez on parle beaucoup et
c'est normal en ce moment des militaires
dell de
alimentaire je dirais des humanitaires
et c'est complètement logique
mais il faut bien voir que c'est aussi
ces valeurs-là qui les pousse et qui
leur donne quelque part ce courage
d'affronter cette adversité
terrible
nicolas tenzer l'objectif de volodymyr
zelensky c'est de s'adresser à la france
qui préside l'union européenne etc
représentent ces valeurs des droits de
l'homme oui c'est pour ça que
l'intervention en france est
particulièrement importante en raison de
cette présidence du conseil de l'union
européenne et je crois que aujourd'hui
nous français nous devons comprendre
aussi
d'abord effectivement qu'il faut
soutenir le crâne totalement
je suis parti je vais partir des
minoritaires je demande depuis le début
le 24 février de cette guerre que nous
européens
nous membres de l'alliance nous nous
engagions militairement nous ne pouvons
pas laisser se reproduire des centaines
de radios sur glâne à nouveau vous êtes
très minoritaire c'est top je suis mis
leur talent vous savez
ça fait 15 ans que je laërt sur la
nature de ce régime que je parle de
monsieur poutine comme un criminel de
guerre que j'alerte sur les crimes de
guerre de ce régime et j'étais aussi
minoritaire donc on a été trop naïve
nous avons été naïfs pour certains
complaisant pour d'autres complices pour
d'autres encore mais ce que vous dites
c'est que s'est engagée la france et les
alliés dans un troisième conflit mondial
se sait pas si c'est un troisième
conflit mondial ja c'est pas le tout ou
rien il ya des manières quand même
d'agir nous avons selon l'article 51 de
la charte des nations unies lorsqu'un
état nous le demande qu'il est attaqué
par une puissance adverse et lorsque cet
état la russie en l'occurrence commet
des crimes de guerre nous avons une
possibilité d'intervenir sur le
territoire de cet état je dis bien sur
le territoire de cet état je parle pas
de la russie pour dissuader ceux qui
commettent de tels crimes concrètement
les chats ruche qui tirent sur des
civils les troupes russes qui abattent
des civils dans la rue on l'a vu à
marioupol notamment à kharkiv et nous
avons aussi le droit lorsque vous avez
des missiles tirés depuis un navire qui
est stationné dans les eaux
territoriales l'ukrainienne concrètement
sur l'amu dans la mer noire nous avons
aussi le droit de dissuader cela et je
pense que nous devons envoyer des
signaux clairs nous connaissions tous
les risques personne ne peut prendre ça
à la légère je comprend effectivement la
difficulté de décisions des chefs de
l'état européen et notamment du
président de la république française
mais je crois qu'il y à un certain
moment est-ce que nous pouvons tout
simplement laissé des civils massacrés
comme nous l'avons fait je veux parler
de radio mais comme nous l'avons fait à
grozny à ses ray-ban chat alep où je le
rappelle toujours monsieur poutine lui
même je parle pas du criminel bachar
el-assad de l'autre criminels mais rien
que les forces russes ont tué plus de
civils syriens que même l'état islamique
alors on va revenir bien évidemment sur
vos propos dans un tout petit instant
mais pour l'heure on va retrouver elsa
mandingue à vaquer se trouve à
l'assemblée nationale salle des quatre
colonnes aux côtés de david habib il est
député socialiste des
pyrénées-atlantiques et membre de la
commission de la défense de l'assemblée
nationale oui et vice président de
l'assemblée nationale quel sens
donnez-vous à la présence d'une grande
partie des députés pour écouter le
président ukrainien c'était un moment
d'union nationale oui c'est un moment
d'union c'est un moment de respect
d'abord à l'égard du peuple ukrainien
qui se bat avec une vaillance et un
courage inouï c'est un moment de respect
à l'égard aussi dieu son président et de
l'ensemble de la classe politique
ukrainienne qui unit a été capable de
dire non à poutine donc on nous sommes
là pour entendre le président de
l'ukraine qui va
j'imagine des comparaisons entre le
combat qui est le sien et celui la
résistance qui évoquera la figure du
général de gaulle comme celle de
françois mitterrand à sarajevo mais on
est là aussi pour être utile il va nous
dire ce dont il a besoin entame d'armes
en terme de deux capacités alimentaires
de médicaments donc on est là pour
l'écouter on espère qu'il va dessiner
aussi une carte de ce que sera l'europe
après la crise parce qu'ils ont un
l'après crise quelles sont les
conditions de la négociation il est père
de la négociation avec poutine on est là
pour l'écouter avec réchou mais aussi
avec intérêt alors avec leur respect on
le sait volodymyr zelensky ce qu'ils
demandent c'est plus d'armes c'est aussi
une zone d'exclusion aérienne
est ce que pour vous maintenant il faut
aller plus loin oui moi je reçus de
c'est ma réponse allait aller elle est
connue depuis longtemps on peut pas
accepter comme ça que des enfants se
fassent massacrer aux portes de de la
france à quelques heures en avion de la
france il ya un moment où il faudra qui
est un acte fort qu'ils soient lancés à
vladimir poutine g pas les cartes en
main je ne suis pas dans l'exécutif est
dans la majorité donc je ne dispose pas
les informations pour pouvoir dire il
faut voter acté la zone d'exclusion
aérienne en revanche ce que je sais
c'est qu'on pourra pas se contenter
d'envoyer des gilets pare-balles et des
casques sauf qu'on a l'impression que
tout geste toute décision peut
déclencher rien de moins qu'une 3e
guerre mondiale j'ai eu
c'est clair il ya un bras de fer qui est
aujourd'hui peut-être
j'ai du mal à utiliser ce terme et une
partie de poker avec poutine en tout
état de cause on ne se fera respecter
que si on est fort on se devra respecter
que si on est unis on se fera respecter
caution tend la main où on prend la main
qui nous est tendu par le président
céline ski on se fera pas respecté si
on apparaît fragile et est soumis à
poutine
merci beaucoup david habib pour vous le
président ukrainien pourrait par exemple
faire appel à cette résistance on verra
si c'est la référence historique choisi
par volodymyr zelensky dans quelques
instants dans l'hémicycle merci beaucoup
est la direction maintenant la salle des
conférences du sénat on va retrouver
quand un calme est kate avec guillaume
gontard le président du groupe
écologiste au sénat oui tout à fait alex
bonjour gontard le wat bonjour séance
extraordinaire avec des députés des
sénateurs qui reviennent pour l'occasion
ici dans les hémicycles des légendes du
parlement vous aussi vous teniez être là
bien sûr bien sûr montrer une forme
d'union nationale c'était la première
question je vais vous poser en tout cas
bien sûr enfin moi ça me paraissait
important indispensable et pour
l'ensemble du groupe écologie solidarité
et territoires d'être là aujourd'hui
c'est effectivement un moment historique
qu'un président d'une démocratie le
président de l'ukraine s'adresse au
parlement au parlement français dans la
situation actuelle une déco mocratie qui
est attaqué par un dictateur et donc
voilà je pense qu'on sera tous attentifs
à ce qu'il a à nous dire à cet appel à
l'aide à cet appel au secours et et à ce
qu'on peut faire pour aider ce peuple
ukrainien qu'est-ce que vous évoque la
personnalité de volodymyr zelensky que
vous allez avoir en vision en direct
dans l'hémicycle comment est ce que vous
le voyez vous cet homme à l'homme d'état
ah ben je pense que je vais assurément
c'est un homme d'état qui a pris la
mesure de la situation dramatique de son
pays je pense que jusqu'à présent il
fait un sans faute avec un courage qui
force qui force le respect et je pense
qu'on doit être attentif à ça et quand
il dit quand le président ukrainien dit
que leur combat contre pour la
démocratie plutôt pour la liberté c'est
aussi notre combat est que si l'ukraine
est envahie que si le russe s'installe
en ukraine on sait très bien le risque
qu'il peut y avoir derrière et donc on
doit être attentif à ce message
volodymyr qui devrait plaider en faveur
de nouvelles sanctions des occidentaux
envers la russie ce sont d'ailleurs des
discussions qui vont avoir lieu demain
avec les réunions du g7 de l'otan et de
l'union européenne jusqu'où faut-il
aller dans ces sanctions selon julio
maman il semble qu'il ya des choses
trois choses très importantes il ya
l'union européenne cette union qu on a
réussi à avoir très rapidement les
sanctions qui ont aidé et j'ai donc déjà
été prises et ça c'est important qu'on
marque cette union la place de l'europe
quand je pense que la solution viendra
avec à travers à travers l'europe
ensuite ya les sanctions il faut bien
sûr aller au delà des sanctions qui ont
déjà été prises je pense qu'il faut
faire un embargo total sur le pétrole et
le gaz bien sûr c'est compliqué bien sûr
ça impliquera un certain nombre de pays
ça sera compliqué et compliqué pour des
pays qui sont très dépendants de ces de
ses ressources mais on le sait il ya
déjà d'ailleurs des pays qui sont
dépendantes et qui appelle justement à
ce blocus parce que c'est que comme ça
qu'on arrivera à faire fléchir vladimir
poutine d'un gris selon elle en france
je moi j'attends aussi une parole très
clair très ferme du gouvernement
français vis-à-vis de total une
entreprise française qui exercent encore
sur le sol russe et ça c'est totalement
inacceptable et ils sont actuellement
complice très rapidement faut-il livrer
davantage d'armes on a vu l'exécutif
ukrainien le demandé également à la
france c'est quelque chose qui peut être
une bonne idée sur votre groupe en tout
cas il faut écouter ce que nous dit le
président ukrainien bien sûr il ya déjà
eu des envois d'armes je pense qu'il
faudra réfléchir aux besoins qu'il ya
mais surtout il faut trouver les
solutions d'une sortie diplomatique
d'arriver à faire en sorte que cette
guerre c'est c'est de retrouver bien sûr
la paix merci merci du gothard merci
quand un call me renaud le bleu vous
avez écouté guillaume compteur est ce
que vous partagez son avis est ce qu'il
faut aller plus loin dans les sanctions
à l'encontre de la russie ce qu'il faut
absolument faire c'est avoir davantage
d'indépendance énergétique parce que
nous finançons d'une certaine manière
la russie à travers l'approvisionnement
en gaz 40% du gaz consommé en europe
vient de russie cela nous coûte à peu
près 700 millions de dollars par jour et
par conséquent il faut diversifier à la
fois les sources d'approvisionnement et
c'est une transition même une révolution
copernicienne qui est en train d'entamer
l'allemagne il ya une véritable
concordance de calendrier entre
l'ultimatum
annoncé par le kremlin au mois de
décembre et le fait que north stream 2
soit véritablement terminée d'un point
de vue technique au mois de décembre et
c'est ensuite le fait d'avoir décidé de
ne pas mettre en service dans scream 2
qui aurait fourni 50 milliards de mètres
cubes de gaz directement de la russie à
l'allemagne aujourd'hui nos stream 1 est
en service et il est à tourner à plein
régime c'est là encore 50 milliards de
mètres cubes de gaz discrédité qu'il ne
faut pas du coup durcir les sanctions
parce que nous n'avons pas les moyens de
notre indépendance énergétique dans
durcir les sanctions c'est une chose
mais la clé selon moi c'est
l'approvisionnement énergétique parce
que c'est ce qu'ils financent la russie
est donc le fait de construire et en
particulier en allemagne qui dépend
considérablement et notamment son
industrie puisque aujourd'hui il ya une
hyper puissance économique en europe qui
est l'allemagne je rappelle qu'il ya
plus de 1000 milliards d'écart de pipe
entre la france et l'allemagne donc elle
est extrêmement consommatrice d'énergie
l'allemagne puisqu'elle est la grande
puissance énergétique en europe et donc
le fait de construire deux nouveaux
ports sur la mer du nord qui vont
pouvoir recevoir du gaz naturel liquéfié
le fait de prolonger les trois centrales
nucléaires encore en activité en
allemagne le fait de prolonger les
centrales au charbon toutes ces
décisions qui était totalement inattendu
du point de vue en particulier d'un
gouvernement en allemagne qui est
composée
d'écologistes de sociaux-démocrates et
de libéraux vont totalement à l'encontre
de ce qui avait été prônée dans la
campagne législative mais on voit bien
que c'est d'une nature delà du
révolution copernicienne qui est engagée
donc cette indépendance énergétique par
rapport à la russie permettra de ne pas
financer la russie jean yves le conte
qu'est ce que doit faire la france dans
ce débat entre les différents états
européens pour durcir les sanctions
contre la russie
je crois qu'il faut enfin chez un petit
peu enfin je suis content de t'entendre
sur ce sujet heureux non je rappelle que
tes amis politiques lorsqu'on parlait de
no strings d'oeil à il ya un an ou deux
considéré que c'était une bonne chose et
nous l'avons vu plusieurs fois la
commission des affaires européennes du
sénat mais en tout cas je crois qu'il
faut aujourd'hui alors que mario pelé
sous les bombes
que les ukrainiens souffrent dans leur
combat et que c'est un miracle tous les
jours que ça tienne grâce à leur volonté
grâce à leur persévérance
il s'agit pas de
vouloir faire des sanctions qui ad vitam
aeternam sont que la russie ne puisse
plus vivre il faut faire en sorte
d'avoir des sanctions qui sont efficaces
rapidement
sans détruire la société russe mais qui
permettent la campagne et qu'elle
fonctionne d'accompagner
d'accompagner le combat des deux
ukrainiens pour hériter agresseurs donc
il faut en particulier aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de livraisons qui se font
à la russie il ya y continuer à voir des
camions qui vont vers la russie peuvent
regarder ce que c'est il faut vraiment
contrôler ce qu'on en voit ce qu'on en
voit aujourd'hui en russie plus plus que
jusqu'à présent on ne sait pas ce qui
arrive mais effectivement il ya une
partie aussi de l'approvisionnement qui
arrivent par des camions qui traversent
l'apologue aujourd'hui il ya un symptôme
d'ukrainiens qui bloque les frontières
qui essaye de les bloquer je crois qu'il
faut vraiment veiller à ça mais je pense
d'abord qu'il est important de 2,2
d'être conscient qu'aujourd'hui il
s'agit plus de savoir si
d'avoir peur de ce que peut faire
poutine
il faut se préparer à ce qu'il annonce
et est déterminé et est solidaire de
ceux qui commencent à combattre c'est à
dire les ukrainiens aujourd'hui
donc les a tous qui approvisionne
la la la la la russie et qui lui permet
de continuer
l'agression vis-à-vis de l'ukraine doit
être doit être stoppée
mais veillons à ne pas détruire non plus
la société la société russe dans son
ensemble parce qu'elles sont là ce
serait un autre problème que nous
aurions derrière c'est qu'une question
de temps pluralité il faut être efficace
rapidement de manière à sauver des vies
et des formes de principe annie
daubenton qu'est ce que vous vous
préconisez est ce qu'il faut aller
crescendo dans les sanctions franchir
une étape de plus que diageo maiden qui
sera en europe demain points un sommet
où est ce qu'il faut aller carrément
verlan barbeau l'embargo russe sur le
gaz sur le pétrole se fait bon moi je
suis quelqu'un qui est une une
observatrice une commentatrice de la
société ukrainienne donc je ne suis pas
là en situation pour distribuer quelques
conseils qui serait au fond
agréable à prononcer mais j'aurais envie
de dire des choses que je pense
que la situation aujourd'hui est telle
qu'on peut pas prodigué des bonnes
paroles il faut les armes et fermer le
ciel je suis désolé de devoir dire ça ce
n'est pas ni dans mon tempérament ni
dans mes attributions mais je ne vois
guère d'autres solutions
quant à l'idée qu' effectivement cela
pourrait amener à un conflit supérieur à
celui que nous vivons je dirais qu'il
est déjà là il faudrait tout simplement
ouvrir les yeux et l'accepter en tant
que tel et après avec lui regardez
comment on peut l'affronter le négocier
on va parler dans cette émission de
l'armement de l'ukraine notamment de la
question aérienne jours et qu'on reste
sur ce sujet énergétique avec peut-être
et bien un futur embargo sur les
hydrocarbures russes en tout cas le
patron du groupe total nrj a décidé de
renoncer au pétrole russe mais pas au
gaz russe il s'explique écouter patrick
pouyanné c'était à ce matin chez nos
confrères d'rtl si nous arrêtons gaz
russe nous savons que nos tally vers
2023 nous avons un problème en janvier
2023 il faudra faut être clair rationner
l'utilisation du gaz pas pour lés
particuliers mais sans aucun doute pour
les industriels en europe paris londres
april faut que les gens il faut qu'on
comprenne ce que l'on fait par ailleurs
toutes ses décisions elles ont un impact
sur les prix il ya un prix cette guerre
il faut être clair
nicolas tenzer on ne peut pas se passer
du gaz russe aujourd'hui en europe c'est
40 % à peu près
moi je pense qu'il ya plusieurs types de
réponses à vers d'abord en ce qui
concerne la france
la france elle peut s'en passer
contrairement à ce que dit monsieur
kouyaté je rappellerai aussi que si vous
pourriez années quand même qu'au
président de la chambre de commerce
franco russe qui a eu depuis le début
dans cette guerre et avant la guerre
depuis 2014 une attitude pour le moins
ambiguë
appelant notamment à la levée des
sanctions et un certain nombre de
personnes y compris l'ancien directeur
et fondateur de cette même chambre
allier avec la russie y compris
puisqu'il est coprésident avec un
coprésident russe mme timochenko qui est
un très proche de vladimir poutine il a
eu des positions qui renforçait
considérablement le discours disons de
complaisance vis-à-vis du crime n'ont
pas demandé à patrick pouyanné de
stopper leurs magasins russes non mais
moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui par rapport
à ce que dit monsieur puyané je pense
que la france doit être exemplaire et
que la france doit cesser immédiatement
je dis bien immédiatement pas de demain
toute importation de gaz russe et de
pétrole de la part de la russie
premièrement deuxièmement il faut aussi
être clairs sur le reste des sanctions
nous avons pas suffisamment nous n'avons
pas suffisamment d'oligarques
aujourd'hui russe de proche du poteau de
routine de comment dire de
propagandistes y compris à la télévision
russe qui sont aujourd'hui sous sanction
on a proposé les ukrainiens l'ont
proposé la fondation que dirige alexeï
navalni vient de reprendre neuf ans
encore de prison on veut dire l'état
totalitaire de ce régime ont proposé des
sanctions additionnelles il faut les
mettre en avait dernier point dernier
point je crois qu'il est aujourd'hui
essentiel de bien songer à l'avenir
nous ne pourrons pas d'abord avoir de
paix de sécurité de stabilité en europe
tant que monsieur poutine sera au
pouvoir
nous ne pouvons donc pas ré entreprendre
comme déjà commencé à le faire un
certain nombre de personnes en allemagne
imaginez un rétablissement un
réengagement une négociation n'importe
quel compromis avec ce régime il doit
être parfaitement clair pour tous les
européens et en particulier pour
emmanuel macron que ce régime est un
régime dont nous souhaitons la
disparition ce n'est pas à nous de le
faire évidemment par la forte personne
ne le propose d'ailleurs ce serait
absurde mais nous devons effectivement
être parfaitement clair là dessus pas de
normalisation avec un état et un
dirigeant qui commet des crimes de
guerre et je crois que il faut le dire
clairement et je pense que le président
de la république tous les dirigeants
européens doivent le dire de la manière
la plus nette qui soit nous repartons
immédiatement à l'assemblée nationale
salle des quatre colonnes pour retrouver
l amont d'un gars vous avec pierre
alexandre anglade qui est député la
république en marge des français établis
hors de france et on débat en plateau du
gaz russe escale et la larme de l'union
européenne face à vladimir poutine voilà
la meilleure arme contre vladimir
poutine c'est l'unité des européens et
depuis le début de cette crise les
européens ont fait preuve de la plus
grande unité en déployant un spectre de
sanctions extrêmement rapide dès les
premiers jours le deuxième le quatrième
hugo le sixième jour trois trains de
sanctions économiques très fort très
puissant qui ont mis un coup sérieux à
l'économie russe maintenant il reste
évidemment des marges de progression
dans le niveau de sanction dans la
dureté de celle ci pour essayer de
freiner vladimir poutine et le faire
arrêter cette guerre absolument ignobles
la question des hydrocarbures du gaz du
pétrole se pose évidemment mais il faut
qu'on reste unie en européen et donc
tant qu'il n'y a pas d'unité tant qu'il
n'y a pas de consensus il faut essayer
de continuer à trouver les voies pour y
arriver c'est de cette façon là qu'on
arrivera à des heures réduire la faim ne
ferait qu affiche est en fait une
désunion de l'europe si on commençait à
voir certains pays dire attention moi je
peux pas m'en passer et c'est pour vous
il vaut mieux à la limite - de sanctions
sur ce domaine mais garder un visage uni
moi je pense que vladimir poutine ne
s'attendait pas au front uni des
européens et vladimir poutine
s'attendait à la division il a trouvé
face à lui des européens qui étaient
absolument soudés et déterminés à lui
opposer la plus grande résistance est
donc ce que je dis c'est que dans ce
moment où l'on se parle toutes les
conditions ne sont pas réunies
aujourd'hui en tout cas pour arriver à
l'interdiction immédiate couper
l'approvisionnement en gaz russe et donc
dès que cela sera possible et que c'est
que les diplomates les uns et les autres
y travaillent eh bien il faudra le faire
mais nous n'y sommes pas encore sur ce
qui va se passer à l'assemblée et au
sénat au delà du symbole de
parlementaires qui écoute le président
ukrainien est ce qu'au niveau
diplomatique ça peut faire bouger les
choses ça peut faire bouger vladimir
poutine d'abord c'est un moment
politique important parce que l'adresse
d'un chef d'état dans l'hémicycle de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat ce
n'est pas quelque chose de banal ce
n'est pas quelque chose de quotidien qui
marque le moment tout à fait
exceptionnel au sens littéral du terme
dans lequel dans lequel nous nous
trouvons est donc cette intervention est
importante parce qu'elle doit permettre
de continuer à éveiller les consciences
dans la société civile parmi nos
concitoyens qui sont des gars très au
fait de ces guerres mais aussi parmi le
personnel politique est évidemment que
nous opposons nous aussi un front uni
sur presque tous les bancs de cette
assemblée et notent cependant qu'il ya
encore quelques responsables ont
tendance à retourner leur veste au gré
des campagnes électorales et dont ce
serait bien qu'ils aient aussi à
entendre ce que leur dit le présent et
dans ce qui saperait min écoutez je
pense qu'ils l'entendront puisqu'on
imagine bien que de penser à certains
responsables politiques candidats marine
le pen sera dans l'hémicycle jean luc
mélenchon aussi nicolas dupont aignan
également merci beaucoup elsa et les
14h30 nous sommes à trente minutes d'un
moment important effectivement le
président ukrainien volodimir et vince
qui va s'exprimer devant les deux
chambres du parlement français on va
prendre la direction du sénat retrouver
quand un calme et en salle des
conférences content ça y est à 30
minutes l'an ou sinon on doit être prêt
pour cet événement j'imagine oui tout à
fait un événement on a compris qui sera
donc en direct à un message à une prise
de parole en direct et diffusé en
simultané dans les deux chambres du
parlement
une prise de parole par visio avec le
logiciel le zoom est un événement
historique et on peut le dire puisque
c'est la première fois qu'on a un chef
d'état étranger dont le message est
diffusé comme cela en direct dans les
hémicycles du parlement et pour
l'occasion un drapeau ukrainien avec
celui de l'union européenne et de la
france a été installé sur la tribune sur
le plateau du sénat les sénateurs qui se
voir remettre en ce moment deux des
petits rubans comme ça des rubans bleu
et jaune qu'ils pourront arborer dans
l'hémicycle au moment d'écouté volodymyr
zelensky il ya également des invités de
marque qui sont disposés et qui sont
invités dans la tribune présidentielle
de l'hémicycle au premier étage on parle
et bien de représentants de l'ambassade
d'ukraine à paris ou encore de la
commission européenne en france avec
cette séance exceptionnelle puisque la
science lui élevé depuis le 26 février
maintenant met donc un symbole un pour
les deux chambres du parlement qui en
même temps vont pouvoir et bien comme
cela affiché une forme d'union nationale
et exprimer une nouvelle fois une forme
d'union une solidarité de la france
envers l'ukraine c'est ce qu'a dit
gérard larcher ces quelques jours merci
quentin qu'elle mène en trouvant à
présent l'islam on à gabat toujours à
l'assemblée nationale est là nous sommes
à moins d'une demi heure de la prise de
parole devant le 10 mars et l'inscrit
dans les hémicycles de l'assemblée
nationale et du sénat et est ce que les
députés seront nombreux cette après midi
pour ce moment historique
alors pour l'instant à une demi-heure de
la séance on n'a pas encore vu beaucoup
de députés mais on sait que tous les
groupes politiques ont évidemment battu
le rappel des troupes pour que
l'hémicycle soit le plus complet
possible pour écouter le président
ukrainien certains députés marine le pen
par exemple candidate avait hésité un
temps à venir et puis elle s'est ravisée
elle sera bien présente à la vite
compris que le symbole comptait beaucoup
en revanche dans cette salle des quatre
colonnes il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
journalistes beaucoup de journalistes
accrédités de la presse française et de
la presse étrangère
effectivement c'est un moment historique
on va vivre à l'assemblée nationale et
au sénat une visioconférence avec un
chef d'état d'un pays en guerre
effectivement députés et journalistes
seront bien présents merci beaucoup l on
a parlé des sanctions notamment
énergétique contre la russie nicolas
tenzer jours à venir ce que ce que vous
disiez en début d'émission est la vraie
solution à ce conflit finalement elle
est militaire et il faut qu'on s'engage
oui absolument encore une fois nous ne
pouvons pas laisser faire nous
connaissons tous les risques un bien sûr
bien sûr qu'il ya des risques mais sauf
que les menaces notamment nucléaires de
monsieur poutine elle exige depuis 2014
sauf que également il faut le rappeler
que depuis 2022 depuis 22 ans gardons
donc depuis 2000 exactement depuis 22
ans monsieur poutine a gagné toutes ces
guerres
il a pu commettre les crimes de guerre
que l'on sait à grozny il a pu envahir
20% du territoire géorgien toujours
occupée il a des forces centristes
transnistrie en moldavie occupée il
occupe de fait le bélarus il a commis
des crimes de guerre massif que l'on
sait en syrie il a commis depuis 2014
des crimes de guerre aussi en ukraine il
faut aussi rappeler un petit à petit
détail c'est pas du tout un détail mais
que dans la crimée occupez vous avez des
tatars de crimée qui sont persécutés
vous avez des disparitions forcées de
perse vous avez dans le dôme bazzoli
région de lougansk et donesk occupé des
prisons la torture donc jusqu'à présent
nous avons laissé faire et donc
aujourd'hui il ya un moment où il faut
arrêter parce que sinon qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce qu'il fera demain et le risque
que l'on invoque notamment le risque
nucléaire il sera tout aussi grand si
demain monsieur poutine décide de s'en
prendre aux pays baltes c'est pas parce
que j'en ai le temps et que l'ukraine ne
l'est pas mais qu'il y aura moins de
risque encore une fois je pense que nous
avons un devoir d'intervention j'ai
rappelé effectivement les conditions
tout à l'heure pas attaqué la russie
mais les forces russes présentes
illégalement en ukraine en vertu de
l'article c'est quoi c'est l'armée
française qui
n'y a pas de troupes au sol je dois
absolument je veux être très clair là
dessus je ne parle pas de troupes au sol
mais nous avons d'abord les moyens
aériens je dirais pour ce faire nous
avons des systèmes antimissiles qu'il
faut donner et aider les ukrainiens
évidemment pour aider les ukrainiens
sont servis remède pour le donner à
l'ukraine pas seulement nous français
j'entends l'ensemble des alliés bien sûr
nous avons équipements la capacité je
dirais par nos propres dispositifs soit
aérien soit navale soit terrestre de
frapper je dirais des batteries je
dirais de domicile stationnés sur des
navires notamment dans les eaux
territoriales ukrainienne nous avons je
dirai tout ses moyens d'action nous
avons la capacité de frapper des
charrues présent en ukraine qui vise le
deyrolle l'otan a les moyens et nous
devons évidemment faire en sorte qu'il
n'y ait plus un seul avion ruche mais je
ne crois pas que c'est pas le point
majeur mais nous devons le faire quand
même qui survolent le ciel craignent ah
oui je dirais nous ne pouvons pas encore
une fois je veux dire si on veut
vraiment répéter continuer à me laisser
monsieur poutine a gagné toutes ces
guerres est uniquement céder à ces
menaces et à son chantage je veux dire
jusqu'où ira-t-il c'est vraiment ce
régime je le dis très clairement sur
régime qu'il faut abattre à battre ronan
le bleu par rapport à ce que vous
entendez ici sur ce plateau vous vous
pensez qu'il faut aller dans un conflit
armé vous pensez qu'il faut répondre aux
demandes du président et l'inscrit
d'armes offensives et est-ce qu'il faut
aller jusqu'à une zone d'exclusion
aérienne
la france est dans un double système
d'alliances au sein de l'otan sein de
l'union européenne
d'ailleurs article 5 du traité de
l'atlantique nord au sein de l'otan
envoie à l'article 42 7 du traité
d'union européenne de protection
et d'engagement si l'un des pays de
l'union européenne de l'otan et en rite
aid devait être attaqué et bien il y à
cette solidarité des membres de l'otan
et de l'union européenne
ce que je partage dans l'analyse c'est
que l'intention n'est pas de s'arrêter
c'est à dire que effectivement
jusqu'où poutine est capable d'aller est
là clairement personne n'est capable de
répondre clairement mais est ce qu'il
est capable de s'arrêter ça c'est une
question qui doit rester à l'analyse
parce que tu réclames on ne sait pas
jusqu'où il est capable d'aller en tout
cas je pense pour ce qui concerne des
états baltes même si c'est peut-être son
intention il y a ce double
cette double alliance de l'otan et de
l'union européenne aujourd'hui la ligne
rouge elle est là est clairement le
déploiement de militaires français en
roumanie
dans les états baltes à travers
l'otan
montrent clairement où se situe du point
de vue de la france la ligne rouge et
rappelons qu'au sein de l'otan il y à un
commandement qui est clairement celui
des etats-unis que nous sommes dans ce
système d'alliances que l'armée
américaine est incroyablement plus
importante que la nôtre le budget est à
peu près de 700 milliards de dollars par
an la france c'est 40 milliards de
dollars par an il faut avoir les sorte
de grandeur aux mesures et ce qu'est
l'alliance de l'atlantique nord et dans
ce contexte eh bien rien ne peut se
faire sans la décision est sans les
états unis c'est ce sont les états unis
qui sont véritablement en qui commande
d'une certaine manière l'otan il faut
avoir conscience de cette année de
bâtons se sont d'accord ce sont les
états unis qui ont finalement la clé
militaire dans ce conflit ou est-ce que
la france qui est quand même une
puissance militaire peut envoyer des
avions pour combattre les chars russes
écoutez en tout cas il est sûr qu'il y a
clé ça c'est sûr il ce dont je suis
certaine aussi c'est que ces
tergiversations
notre attente is notre lenteur à
répondre c'est vrai que cette solidarité
européenne et occidentale a été
magnifique elle a été exemplaire mais
tout ça il ne faut pas oublier que ce
sont des messages pour le kremlin que le
kremlin perçoit sa parfaitement que
depuis le début les différents discours
de poutine et de ses conseillers
c'est regarder ça va se passer comme
d'habitude ils vont faire quelques
sanctions mais pour nous c'est pas grand
chose au contraire ça va nous fortifier
et puis ils vont peu à peu se lasser et
on pourra faire ce que nous avons à
faire donc ça c'est vrai que c'est un
langage qui est parfaitement
compréhensible pour le kremlin et que
par ses tergiversations ou l'encouragent
monsieur le comte j'arrive le contexte
qu'il faut aller vers plus de d'armes
fourni à l'ukraine pour l'aider dans ce
dans ce conflit on sait que kiev et ait
complètement encerclées aujourd'hui à
siéger presque
je pense que oui on n'a pas tout à fait
tergiverser malgré tout d'une certaine
manière je crois que la réaction
européenne même si elle n'est pas la
hauteur de l'enjeu encore elle est quand
même qu'on n'aurait pas imaginé que
l'union européenne finance des armes
pour un pays qui n'était pas un état
membre donc d'une certaine manière
l'europe est plus soudé que jamais sur
sa donc on peut pas non plus parler de
temps totalement de tergiversations je
crois effectivement qu'il faut
poursuivre les efforts et aller plus
loin on répondre à la question le
président e bagdad sera en europe cette
semaine j'espère que les états unis vont
évoluer quant à la fourniture d'avions
aux ukrainiens parce que ils en ont
besoin ils en ont besoin de la même
manière je crois qu'il est indispensable
que les sites de l'industrie chimique et
les centrales nucléaires en ukraine soit
clairement protéger d'une manière
spécifique je comprends que même je
reçus des parlementaires aux lituaniens
tant que même lorsqu'on leur parle de la
no fly zone ils sont un peu voilà un peu
partagé parce qu'ils comprennent que ça
peut être tout de suite un engrenage
incontrôlable donc s'en allait peut-être
jusqu'à la no fly zone
je n'ai pas les éléments pour savoir si
ça peut être réaliste son escalade
absolue ou pas mais en tout état de
cause sur les sites chimiques et
nucléaires serre des centrales
nucléaires et l'industrie chimique avoir
des dispositifs spécifiques je crois que
c'est indispensable et puis et puis
faire en sorte effectivement parce que
j'entends ce que vous dites monsieur
mais si personne n'est prêt à aller
jusqu'à moscou finalement il faut aussi
compter sur les russes pour faire une
partie du travail absolument voilà
donc ce qui est important effectivement
c2d de permettre aux ukrainiens de
continuer à tenir de l'armée russe en
échec sur le territoire de l'ukraine sur
l'ensemble du territoire de l'ukraine
allez on va retrouver quand enfin calmée
dans la salle des conférences du sénat
quentin vous êtes avec car laurent le
président du groupe communiste au sénat
et à les communistes c'est intéressant à
analyser car ils ont plutôt une position
un pacifiste et ils sont plutôt opposés
à un armement de l'ukraine alors il pas
mon dieu du groupe 1 céline assassine
réflexion il est membre il est pas prise
d'un groupe et vous êtes membre du
groupe communiste on a ce débat en
plateau jusqu'où faut-il aller dans
l'armement des ukrainiens faut-il aller
jusqu'à une no fly zone c'est une une
exclusion comme ça de vue du ciel aérien
avec des avions français en face des
agents russes quelle est la position de
votre groupe sur cette question qui
alors je crois que nous nous savons
depuis le début que
la création d'une no fly zone qui
signifierait la possibilité pour un
avion de l'otan d'une armée de l'otan
d'abattre en aviron signifierait
l'entrée en guerre de l'otan donc nous
ne sommes pas favorables à cette entrée
en guerre et voilà sur la no fly zone
oui il ya des négociations qui vont
avoir lieu demain avec l'otan avec
également l'union européenne faut-il de
nouvelles sanctions - faut-il livrer des
armes ou est-ce que vous vous
positionnez vous sur les sanctions je
pense que
il faut faire le bilan de toutes les
sanctions qui ont été prises elles sont
déjà très importante il faut apprécier
leur impact et si il ya besoin de les
renforcer pour isoler le réel pouvoir de
poutine pour frapper ce qu'ils financent
et que ce soit utile à l'obliger à
stopper la guerre et à revenir à la
table de négociations il faut envisager
ces hypothèses mais les sanctions
doivent être appréciés en fonction de
leur utilité je prends un exemple on
vient d'exclure la russie du conseil de
l'europe il ya une contrepartie amer à
cette sanction c'est que les russes
qu'ils pouvaient importer plainte devant
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
ne peuvent plus le faire donc il faut
apprécier à l'intelligence des sanctions
il s'agit bien de frapper poutine pas
frapper les russes en quelques mots
faut-il mettre en place un embargo sur
le gaz et le pétrole russe voit que ça
fait débat cela aussi ça coûterait
peut-être très cher aux consommateurs
français qu'est ce que vous en pensez
c'est surtout qu'il ya certains pays
européens qui eux sont extrêmement
dépendants du gaz russe pour leur
approvisionnement énergétique
puisque pouvoir d'achat non mais c'est
pas seulement laisser les scellés de
toute façon la crise énergétique qu'elle
avait démarré avant la guerre elle est
très importante à la d'autres causes que
seulement ça il ya aussi des profiteurs
de guerre qui spécule beaucoup qui en
profitent pour spéculer c'est peut-être
aussi cela qu'il faudrait stopper il
nous reste quelques secondes on attend
ce moment un peu historique 1 ce message
dans quelques minutes de volodymyr
zelensky dans l'hémicycle qu'est-ce que
vous inspire votre groupe qui sera
investi à présent largement aujourd'hui
passer un message exceptionnel c'est une
situation exceptionnelle on n'a pas
l'habitude de ce type de message
j'espère qu'on aura au delà de ce qu'on
sait de la guerre peut-être un appel
à l'appel au cessez-le-feu en tout cas
des nouvelles de la possibilité de
retourner au plus vite à des discussions
et un arrêt de la guerre parce que je
crois que c'est ça qui est urgent en
tout cas dans l'immédiat eh bien on
verra ça donc à partir de 15h pierre
laura mercier merci merci quand un calme
est nicolas tenzer l'otan annonce
qu'elle va apporter un soutien
supplémentaire contre les attaques
nucléaires et chimiques à l'ukraine est
ce que ces menaces sont crédibles mais
je pense qu'ils sont crédit maintenant
il faudra voir le détail du dispositif
qui va être décidé par le temps parce
que jeudi rapporté très concrètement
effectivement je dirais d'une protection
comme ça a été dit par jean yves le
conte très justement tout à l'heure
comment ça se passe je dire moi je ne
vois pas que ça puisse se passer sans
des dispositifs antimissiles et sans je
dirais une capacité aussi de viser des
avions russes qui pourrait menacer ces
centrales voire même des troupes au sol
qui pourraient pénétrer dans ses
environs donc si le temps le fais moi je
ne pourrais que l'applaudir j'attends de
voir très concrètement comment comment
crédible à une attaque à l'armé chimique
une attaque nucléaire ça vous paraît
possible écoutez avec monsieur poutine
malheureusement tout est possible
maintenant il faut pas jouer assez
report non plus parce qu'il faut savoir
j'étudie comme depuis une dizaine
d'années la propagande du kremlin je
sais que ça fait partie aussi de la
rhétorique du kremlin c'est-à-dire
défrayer des dirigeants est encore plus
bien sûr les opinions publiques
occidentales pour dire vous voyez déjà
ses prix en 2014 si vous riposter vous
serez les responsables de la troisième
guerre mondiale ça c'est le discours du
kremlin et je pense qu'il ya un certain
moment il faut arrêter de prendre cela
on a vu d'ailleurs même il ya trois
jours vous savez avec la fameuse bombe
nouvelle à détectable ça faisait partie
de la rhétorique et on a vu un certain
nombre de personnes
journalistes personnalités politiques
intellectuels qui rôle là vous voyez le
kremlin attention attention c'est
exactement ce que veut le crabe et donc
faisons vraiment attention à ne pas
acheter ça vraiment content parce que
voilà on fait le jeu de l'ennemi et je
pense qu'il n'y a pas assez
d'information et pas assez de décryptage
d' alerte et de compréhension de la
manière dont joue cette propagande en
france dans notre pays d'ailleurs renan
le bleu est ce que l'utilisation d'armes
chimiques biologiques contre la
population ukrainienne est ce que cela
doit être une ligne rouge et entraîné
l'engagement des occidentaux vraiment
militaire dans ce qu'on fait ce qui est
indispensable c'est que si on définit
ligne rouge alors ça doit entraîner une
réaction on ne peut pas comme en syrie
définir une ligne rouge de l'utilisation
des armes chimiques et une fois
franchies ne rien faire voilà c'est ça
qui est important
la ligne rouge une fois qu'elle est
définie elle entraîne une conséquence
donc ce sera un risque stratégique
finalement de poser cette ligne rouge il
faut la paix on ne peut la pause et qu'à
condition de véritablement avoir
derrière la décision d'agir or ce qui
s'est passé en syrie à décrédibiliser
une partie de la du propos tenus donc
voilà c'est ce que je tiens à rappeler
on ne l'a défini qu'à condition que
derrière ces enclenche directement une
action si je peux bien jouer une petite
le petit pois 1 je suis complètement
d'accord avec ce que vous venez de dire
effectivement la goutte à 2013 l'abandon
d'obama ça a été la catastrophe
deuxièmement est-ce que la ligne rouge
ça uniquement parce que c'est prohibées
par les conventions internationales
l'usagé d'armes chimiques
bactériologiques et bien sûr nucléaire
ou est-ce que c'est déjà l'assassinât en
plein jour d'enfants de civils
brutalement directement comme on l'a vu
il ya aussi la question de la définition
qu'est ce qu'on considère comme étant la
ligne rouge est ce que c'est lié à un
traité ou est-ce que c'est lié aussi à
l'absence de respect de la convention de
base
et concernant la protection des
populations civiles ou les hôpitaux ou
chez vous la ligne rouge moi je ne veux
pas rentrer dans ce jeu là c'est quand
on bombarde une maternité quand on fait
les crimes de guerre qui sont faits tous
les jours c'est ce qu'ils font tous les
jours ce
qui se passe actuellement 20 considéré
comme acceptable non non il faut arrêter
ça et se donner les moyens de l'arrêter
bien entendu vous avez probablement vu
que le présent gelid qui est qui et qui
est
finalement assez modérée par rapport à
quand on regarde et une très bonne heure
et quand on voit son intervention son
interview hier devant la presse
internationale
il parle de cessez le feu de négociation
d'un référendum pour valider ce qui
pourrait être ensuite fait pour les
négociations voilà il sait bien que que
que le principal c'est de préserver la
paix mais de préserver la paix à des
conditions qui permettent effectivement
aux ukrainiens de deux d'être
d'être libre et indépendant mais je ne
vois pas dans les circonstances
actuelles comment nous pouvons sans
cynisme parler d'une ligne rouge elle
est franchi toutes les lignes rouges
sont franches et tous les jours nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans un génocide
voilà lorsque l'on voit ce qui se passe
à marioupol lorsqu'on voit ce qui se
passe dans cette maternité lorsqu'on
voit ce qui se passe sur les pseudos
coco couloirs humanitaires qui sont qui
sont qui et quand on voit des voilà
comment voulez vous parler du niveau
rouge
en fait je parle de crimes de guerre je
parle on peut parler de génocide quand
on voit ce qui se passe à marioupol donc
à partir de là mais tout petit à petit
en capacité d'accompagner effectivement
on aura une dimension nouvelle s'il y
avait des conséquences sur une sur une
usine chimique sur une centrale
nucléaire ou même de luz usage de
2-2 d'armes chimiques ou nucléaires
mais c'est ce qui qui exige que nous
nous préparions il n'y a pas de ligne
rouge elles sont toutes franchies les
unes après les autres a nié daubenton
est-ce que vous parlez aussi de génocide
en ukraine bon écoute et vous savez avec
ce vocabulaire je pense que c'est c'est
déjà le travail de l'histoire de
l'historien c'est vraiment plus que
prématurée par contre je suis tout à
fait d'accord pour le dire que les
toutes les lignes rouges ont déjà été
franchies qu'il faut pas plaisanter avec
ceux de ce vocabulaire c'est vrai que
quand on voit ce qui se passe à
tchernobyl a zo porchier ces gens qui
travaillent en comme otages
désarmement désarmez russe pour
continuer à travailler sur ces centrales
quand on voit les risques qui ont été
pris de déchets nucléaires qui ne sont
plus gérés ces centrales ne sont
absolument plus surveillés leïla déjà
vraiment préciser dit c'est un danger
absolu quant aux il ya eu également des
des
pardons avec l'ammonium des déchets
biologiques qui ont été qui ont excusé
moi qui ont été lancés dans la nature et
qui n'étaient là aussi pas sous contrôle
donc c'est vrai que on joue avec le feu
et que ce n'est plus seulement les
questions vraiment militaire humanitaire
c'est qu'on est en train de
déstructurer complètement un territoire
qui avait qui étaient sous contrôle
soûles et sous le contrôle d'un pouvoir
démocratique
qui ne peut plus exercer ce contrôle et
qui ne peut plus en exercer les
responsabilités
de ce contrôle et on continue la
rédaction avec quentin calmer dans la
salle des rangs du sénat quand vous êtes
avec christian cambon le président de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées du sénat
tout à fait bonjour christian cambon
joue un mot du symbole comment est ce
que vous le qualifiez c'est un moment
historique qui s'apprête à être vécue au
sénat et à l'assemblée nationale c'est
un symbole fort parce que d'abord il
réunit les deux assemblées en même temps
duplex par ailleurs le fait de
s'adresser
directement à la représentation
nationale or la présence de membres du
gouvernement il n'y aura pas de
ministres est rarissime
je crois que c'est bien le signe que le
présent et l'ins qui veut prendre à
partie en quelque sorte l'opinion
nationale française que nous
représentons les uns et les autres à des
titres divers et je crois que ça va
permettre aussi de pour lui de délivrer
un message fort
si le sien prône l'envoi de nouvelles
armes ou encore est le fait qu'ils aient
de nouvelles sanctions est ce que vous
seriez d'accord avec cela est ce qu'il
faut le suivre jusqu'où faut-il aller
justement il faut il faut l'aider de
toute façon puisque c'est la décision de
l'europe toute entière nous ne sommes
pas les seuls dans ses actions je crois
que nous avons posé les jalons de
l'action européenne qui vise évidemment
à ne pas rentrer sur le théâtre des
opérations pas directement sur la
direction montré une réussite ça
entraînerait on le sait très bien avec
les intentions de monsieur poutine ça
entraînerait ça risquerait d'entraîner
un conflit nucléaire dont il n'est pas
question de radio no-fly zone demain car
ce
n'est techniquement pas possible
maintenant tout ce qui peut être fait
par ailleurs les faits on le fait et je
crois que c'est dans cet esprit qu
effectivement il faut voir ce lien et je
moi je suis très attentif à ce que
monsieur ait un ce qui va nous dire je
crois que ça l'a portée de son message
est très importante oui est ce que vous
savez vous au niveau des informations
qui vous remonte de l'armée française
est ce que l'on sait exactement des
théâtres d'opération en ce moment en
ukraine vous avez des informations aussi
là dessus oui je suis je suis évidemment
informés à la fois fin d'un double
mouvement une forte résistance
ukrainienne on le voit est pas été
anticipée peut-être par les revoilà et
le même aujourd'hui deux villes ou
villages qui aurait été repris par les
ukrainiens mais il faut être assez
attentif aussi à ce qui se passe du côté
russe car je crois que la russie reforme
en quelque sorte ses troupes les remet
au format et je pense que il n'y avait
pas les rangs je suis pas certain que le
présent poutine avait tous les
renseignements sur l'état des forces
ukrainienne et de l'opinion ukrainienne
un dernier mot très rapide à se demander
aussi une réunion de l'otan avec joe
biden qui vient escient en europe qui
ramène en pologne vendredi est ce qu'on
peut attendre là encore des décisions
des nouvelles sanctions qu'est ce que
vous en pensez pour l'instant on voit
qu'il n'ya au les termes d'aucun accord
donc je pense que le risque c'est des
nouvelles sanctions mais il faut aussi
garder quelque part le fil du dialogue
car il faudra dès que ce conflit se
termine merci merci qu'il soit comment
pour votre réaction à notre micro en
direct merci quand un calme et on prend
tout de suite la direction de
l'assemblée nationale salle des quatre
colonnes l amont d'un gars va vous êtes
avec sébastien chez nous il est député
rassemblement national du nord oui quand
votre candidate marine le pen a été
interrogé sur sa présence à elle hésite
et au début un petit peu à venir elle
s'est ravisée elle a compris l'enjeu du
symbole il était compliqué pour elle
d'être présente elle est en pleine
campagne électorale et puis ils vont ce
qu'un moment hortense et donc elle a
fait le choix de venir de perturber son
agenda pour revenir pour témoigner
effectivement de la nécessité d'être là
pendant ce moment important le président
ukrainien demande à la france à l'union
européenne d'en faire plus de prendre
peut-être plus de risques quelle est la
position au rassemblement national et
nous sommes favorables aux sanctions à
partir du vent elle n'impacte pas les
français dans leur quotidien et en
particulier dans leur pouvoir d'achat
nous c'est nous protégeons les français
notre boussole c'est protéger les
français leur pouvoir d'achat leur
sérénité alors oui pour des sanctions
oui trois fois oui mais pour qu'elle
soit bien mesurer et qu'elles soient
pertinentes pour ne pas finalement ce
tir et à nous mêmes une balle dans le
pied donc on ne touche pas au gaz ou
pétrole près pétrole russe alors qu'on
sait que ce sont des leviers entre
vladimir poutine l'homme est touché aux
énergies ça veut dire un renchérissement
des énergies ici ça veut dire que la
facture va exploser ça veut dire que les
français vont voir leur facture exploser
par 4 5 ou 6 il ya d'autres à sanctions
qui sont possibles il à vis des
oligarques vis-à-vis d'un certain nombre
de banques les habitudes de fonds
souverains russes il y à des sanctions
qui sont possibles il faut activer
scellier mais attention à ce que ça ne
nous reviennent pas avec le blocage des
énergies en boomerang c'est tout ce que
nous demandons et puis de toute façon la
solution aller diplomatique au bout du
compte est ce qu'elle est militaire
également des livraisons d'armes une
zone d'exclusion aérienne par exemple
sur l'écran pas du tout parce que ça te
ferait de nous des co belligérance est à
dire qu on entrerait dans le conflit
puisque nous sommes dans l'otan et que
l'as d'escaladé à serez amenés
évidemment à des choses probablement
bien plus dangereuse pour la france donc
pas de livraisons d'armes pas d'espacé
rien exclusif mais simplement des
sanctions financières qui peuvent
frapper la russie et puis surtout la
diplomation n'en sortira par la
diplomatie donc vous allez écouter le
message de l'audi merengue mais vous
vous allez lui dire non à tout
finalement nous n'allons pas lui dire
non à tout puisque nous sommes
favorables à des sanctions mais surtout
favorable à ce que la france avec ses
partenaires et bien essayé d'amener
autour de la table l'écho belligérants
les belligérants pour trouver une sortie
diplomatique c'est la seule solution
merci beaucoup sébastien chenu vous
l'avez bien la présidente femmes
l'ancien président du rassemblement
national candidate marine le pen sera
bien présente dans les mystiques
merci beaucoup elsa messieurs les
sénateurs jean yves le conte et ronan le
gleut je vais vous libérer un parce que
vous devez vous rendre et bien dans
l'hémicycle du sénat le discours de
volodymyr zelinska devant le parlement
français va commencer dans quelques
minutes vous aurez qu on garde une image
qui s'est passé ce matin justement un
groupe d'amitié france ukraine au sénat
s'est rendu devant l'ambassade de russie
à paris pour protester contre le non
respect du droit international dans ce
conflit s'était donc ce matin et puis
les seat ont également à dénoncer la
situation des civils dans des villes
ukrainiennes comme marioupol et et bien
l'obligation de respecter l'ouverture de
couloirs humanitaires nicolas tenzer
justement dans ce conflit la situation
des civils c'est une catastrophe oui ça
a été dit tout à l'heure c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on a des crimes de guerre
massif non seulement vous avez au bas
mot plus de 120 enfants qui sont déjà
mortes dans ce conflit des milliers de
civils on n'a pas encore les chiffres
mais en tout cas ça sauf scène se
chiffrent par milliers qui ont été
encore une fois délibérément pris pour
cible par l'armée russe et les forces
russes vous avez eues il c'était une
image était un symbole absolument
terrible vous avez urban danisco qui a
été tué c'était un homme de 95 ans qui
était un survivant des camps de
buchenwald de doral de bergen belsen et
qui a trouvé la mort qui avait échappé à
hitler il a été tué par poutine
il a plein d'autres bien sûr mais je
trouve que c'est le symbole aussi que
cette histoire et je crois
qu'effectivement devant ces crimes de
guerre massif et sage aussi c'est une
résolution faudra aller jusqu'au bout je
donne pour les bus lire je pense qu'il
n'ya pas de réconciliation
possible alors qu'on voit le président
du sénat gérard larcher qui entrent dans
la galerie des bustes du sénat pour
diriger dans l'hémicycle à quelques
minutes maintenant du discours de
bologne en scène ce qui effectivement
gérard larcher qui va prendre la parole
dès 15 heures se fera dans une minute
trente maintenant en la parole pour
annoncer et bien l'allocution de
volodymyr celles inscrites devant le
parlement français c'est un moment
historique à l'assemblée nationale comme
au sénat puisque richard ferrand prendra
également la parole deux minutes plus
tard pour annoncer cette intervention
qui sera donc simultané dans les deux
hémicycles alexandre alors qu'on voit
également richard ferrand se diriger
vers l'hémicycle du de l'assemblée
nationale annie daubenton juste avant le
début
de ses discours un mot sur la situation
humanitaire on parlait de couloirs
humanitaires il ne fonctionne pas
vraiment il fonctionne très
difficilement et parfois les armées
russes en profite pour s'infiltrer dans
les villes donc ils peuvent se
fonctionner également dans ce sens là et
aussi il ya énormément d'enfants qui
passent la frontière sol et on en voit
arriver y compris à paris voilà donc ça
donne une idée du drame qui est en train
de tomber sur ce pays nous voyons
effectivement en direct ces images du
président de l'assemblée nationale
richard ferrand qui a traversé est la
galerie des fêtes de l'assemblée
nationale qui se trouve actuellement
dans la salle des pas perdus qui mène
tout droit à l'entrée de l'hémicycle il
va arriver au perchoir dans quelques
minutes pour prononcer un très très bref
discours juste annoncé cette allocution
historique de volodymyr celle inscrit le
président ukrainien devant la chambre
des députés et puis au même moment et
bien il s'exprimera devant les sénateurs
et c'est gérard larcher qui va prendre
la parole dans un tout petit instant on
lui dans un tout petit instant le
président du sénat gérard larcher
inaugurera cette séance ce moment
historique important le discours du
président ukrainien volodimir les émirs
zemlinsky devant les deux chambres du
parlement français volodymyr synesci qui
continue donc sa tournée ces discours
devant les parlements des différentes
puissances occidentales il s'exprimait
ce matin devant le parlement japonais et
il s'est exprimé hier devant les
parlementaires italiens volodymyr
zelensky qui devrait normalement faire
déréférencer bien à l'histoire française
à la révolution française à la
résistance française pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale ah c'est sa méthode
touché la corde sensible à des pays
auxquels il s'adresse pour et bien
augmenté intensifier le soutien de
l'occident à l'ukraine dans cette guerre
c'est effectivement ce qui l'a fait
devant le parlement italien hier et puis
devant le parlement allemand il ya
quelques jours également devant le
congrès américain regardez ces images à
présent des députés debout une standing
ovation avant le discours de volodymyr
et l'inscrit un hémicycle qui est
évidemment très remplie alors que vous
le savez les travaux sont suspendus pour
cause de campagne
présidentielle le drapeau ukrainien est
également en essais dans l'hémicycle de
l'assemblée nationale gérard larcher
voilà monsieur le président d'ukraine
monsieur le président de l'assemblée
nationale
nommé messieurs les députés et sénateurs
mes chers collègues dames et messieurs
les représentants du corps diplomatique
le moment est solennel
les circonstances l'inédite
pour la première fois de notre histoire
parlementaire
nous accueillons le président d'un pays
en guerre
d'un pays à la capitale a siégé
sur lesquelles les frappes redoublent
d'intensité en ce moment même
car l'inadmissible est en train de se
produire
la guerre en europe aux portes de
l'union européenne la guerre en ukraine
votre peuple monsieur le président
d'ukraine force l'admiration
alors qu'il est la cible d'une agression
que rien ne peut justifier
alors qu'il est la victime d'un appétit
de conquête territoriale qui fait voler
en éclats toutes les règles de la
communauté internationale alors qu'il
est la proie de la folie meurtrière des
autorités russes
le peuple ukrainien se bat
les ukrainiens civils et militaires
résiste jusqu'à l'héroïsme
pour défendre la souveraineté de leur
pays et leur liberté aux yeux de
l'europe et du monde
je souhaiterais mes chers collègues
parlementaires avec les membres du
conseil de paris que je salue et qui
nous écoute que nous nous levions et
applaudissions afin de rendre hommage au
courage du peuple ukrainien et le vous
même monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
mes chers collègues
mesdames et messieurs le temps n'est pas
seulement à l'émotion il est avant tout
à l'action vous nous direz dans un
instant monsieur le président d'ukraine
ce que vous attendez de notre pays la
france
permettez moi de vous remercier d'avoir
fait le choix en pleine tourmente de
vous adresser au parlement des grandes
démocraties
et si régulièrement au parlement
français pour transmettre le témoignage
de l'ukraine et de vos attentes
ne doutez pas de notre soutien pour
aujourd'hui et pour l'avenir
votre respect de l'institution
parlementaire
distingue votre pays de ses adversaires
il fait sens quand son combat l'ukraine
défend aussi nos valeurs celles de la
démocratie de l'humanisme de la liberté
de la civilisation européenne
oui parce que l'ukraine appartient à la
famille européenne
je vais maintenant donner la parole aux
présidents ferrand qui va prendre la
suite monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
de l'assemblée nationale richard ferrand
qui va mieux le président de l'ukraine
monsieur le président du sénat mesdames
et messieurs les députés sénateurs
mesdames et messieurs les représentants
du corps diplomatique
c'est un honneur pour nous de vous
accueillir au sein de l'assemblée
nationale
nous connaissons votre attachement à la
france où vous avez effectué votre
premier déplacement officiel à
l'étranger
après votre élection comme président de
l'ukraine vous aviez ainsi engagé dès
2019 un dialogue fructueux avec la
france je tiens également à saluer la
présence parmi nous de l'ambassadeur
d'ukraine en france monsieur vadim
omeltchenko
ipic
depuis maintenant près d'un mois de
guerre les ukrainiens se bat et résiste
de façon héroïque à l'agression
militaire russe soyez sûr monsieur le
président de la solidarité et de
l'entière mobilisation de la
représentation nationale nous
continuerons de veiller à ce que tout
soit mis en oeuvre pour vous porter
assistance qu'il s'agisse de l'adoption
de mesures restrictives à l'encontre de
l'agresseur de la fourniture d'un
soutien humanitaire aux ukrainiens comme
réfugiés nous avons tous vu ces images
choquantes bouleversante de villes
ukrainiennes bombardée et assiégée
la france condamne ces actes et ses
bombardements indiscriminés
visant les populations civiles cela doit
s'arrêter immédiatement et nous appelons
la russie à se conformer au droit
international humanitaire dans ces
circonstances tragiques
le peuple ukrainien fait preuve d'une
résistance admirable je tiens à saluer
son courage et celui des autorités
ukrainiennes
sachez que nous demeurons à vos côtés
monsieur le président de l'ukraine vous
avez la parole
m
merci
merci c'est un grand honneur pour moi
pour le cren et pour notre peuple
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
mesdames et messieurs les parlementaires
les élus de paris le peuple français
je suis reconnaissant d'avoir l'honneur
de m'adresser à vous aujourd'hui
je suis sûr que vous savez très bien ce
qui se passe en ukraine vous savez
pourquoi cela s'est produit et vous
savez qui est coupable
et même ceux qui ceux qui cachent la
tête dans le sable
et c'est de trouver de l'argent en
russie
et je m'adresse à vous aux gens honnêtes
rationnelle et audacieux
et je voudrais poser une question
comment arrêter cette guerre comment
instaurer la paix en ukraine parce que
la plupart des questions et des réponses
sont dans vos mains dans nos mains le 9
mars
les bombes aériennes russes ont été
lancés sur l'hôpital pour les enfants et
une maternité dans notre vie de mario
paul c'était une ville
paisible dans le sud est de l'ukraine
complètement paisible jusqu'à ce que les
troupes russes sont venus et l'ont pris
dans son siège brutal comme au moyen âge
ils ont commencé à tuer les les gens
dans cette maternité
sur lesquels le russe ont lancé les
bombes il avait des gens il y avait des
femmes qui se préparait à accoucher et
la plupart d'entre eux
ont survécu mais certaines ont été
gravement blessés
et une femme et diot a amputé son pied
qui était fracturée et une autre femme
avait en bassin fracturé et son bébé est
mort avant la naissance
la femme on a on essayait de sauver la
femme
elle demandé les médecins de laisser
mourir de ne pas l'aider
elle n'avait pas de réelle ne voyez pas
des raisons pour vivre
elle est morte en ukraine en europe en
quand des centaines de millions de
personnes ne peuvent pas penser que que
le monde pouvait être détruits
et je vous demande d'observer une minute
de silence à l'honneur à la mémoire des
milliers des lustres aignan et d'ukraine
yen qui ont été tuées à la suite de
l'invasion russe du territoire ukrainien
merci merci
après les semaine dans voici en russe
marie paule et d'autres villes
ukrainiennes frappé par l'occupant
rappelle les ruines de verdun
comme sur les photos de la première
guerre mondiale
que chacun et chacune
à vue a vu l'armée russe ne distingue
pas les objets qu'il cible ils
détruisent tous les quartiers
résidentiels les hôpitaux les écoles les
universités tôt il brûlait les entrepôts
de nourriture et de médicaments
ils brûlent tout
il le prend pas en compte et les
concepts de crimes de guerre
les obligations sur les confessions et
sont apportées la terreur sur la seule
ligne à
et chacun de vous en est conscient vous
avez toutes les informations tout est
disponible tous les faits sur les femmes
violées par les militaires russes dans
les zones temporairement occupés sur les
réfugiés
qu'ils tuent sur les routes sur les
journalistes et keltoum sachant
exactement que ce sont des journalistes
sur les anciens qui ont survécu à
l'holocauste et et sont maintenant
obligés de fuir dans les abris anti
banques des frappes russe
l'europe
n'a pas vu depuis 80
temps l'europe n'a pas vu ce qui se
passe en ukraine
il y a des gens désespérés qu'il supplie
de mourir
en 2019 quand je suis devenu président
il y avait des gens en format pour les
négociations avec la fédération de la
russie c'était un format normandie le
format de négociations qui devraient
mettre fin à la guerre dans le donbass
la guerre à l'est de l'ukraine et qui
dure depuis huit ans malheureusement
et quatre états ont participé au format
normandie lui prenne la russie
l'allemagne et la france
4 mais il représentait tout le monde le
monde entier les positions du monde
entier toutes les positions quelqu'un
l'insulté news quelqu'un a essayé de
retarder le processus et ils voulaient
le perturber mais il semblait important
que le monde soit toujours à cette table
ne rebondit
et quand il y avait des résultats des
négociations quand nous avons réussi à
libérer les gens de la captivité quand
nous avons pu négocier certaines
décisions en 2010 neuf c'était une
bouffée d'air frais comme une leur
d'espoir l'espoir que le conversation
avec le récit peuvent était que les
dirigeants de la russie peuvent être
persuadé par les paroles que moscou
que choisir la paix mais le 24 février
veille ou le jour qui a barré tous les
efforts
et même le concept du mou dialogue
et la barre et l'expérience européenne
de relations avec la russie elle est
décidée l'histoire en europe tout cela a
été bombardée par les troupes russes
écrasé par l'artillerie russe et brûlé
après les tirs de missiles russes
on n'a pas trouvé de vérité dans les
bureaux
et on est obligé de chercher la vérité
sur le champ de bataille
alors qu'est ce qui nous reste nos
valeurs l'unité et la détermination de
défendre notre liberté
notre liberté commune pour paris et pour
kiev
or berlin et varsovie pour madrid et
rome pour bruxelles et pratice lave
les bouffées d'air frais ne nous
aideront pas
et nous devons agir ensemble de faire la
pression ensemble pour faire la russie a
cherché la peine mesdames et messieurs
le peuple français le 24 février
le peuple ukrainien s'est unie et
aujourd'hui nous n'avons plus ni de
représenter en trois nuits représentants
de gauche nous ne faisons pas attention
à ce qui est ce qui représentait le
pouvoir
et la coalition et l'opposition et on
pense de l'instauration de la paix
pour protéger notre pays nous sommes
reconnaissants à la france
que la france nous aide nous sommes très
reconnaissants pour les efforts du
président macro qui a fait preuve d'un
véritable leadership nous communiquons
constamment avec lui nous coordonnons
nos pas et les ukrainiens on voit que la
france apprécie également la vérité et
vous la protéger
vous vous savez ce que c'est la liberté
l'égalité la fraternité
et chaque parole est important pour vous
je le sens et les ukrainiens le récente
et nous attendons de la france de votre
leadership
que vous puissiez faire en sorte que la
russie cherche la peine pour mettre fin
à cette guerre contre la liberté contre
l égalité entre la fraternité
contre tout skieur rendu l'europe unie
et
libre et diverses nous attendons de la
france de votre leadership la
restauration de l'intégrité territoriale
de l'ukraine on peut le faire ensemble
et il ya ceux qui ont des doutes entre
les personnes présentes alors je peux
vous dire que votre peuple est sûr comme
tous les autres peuples de l'europe
et pendant la présidence française de
l'union européenne
une décision
mûrie surprise sur l'adhésion de
l'ukraine à l'union européenne une
décision historique à un moment
historique
comme cela a toujours été le cas dans
l'histoire du peuple français
mesdames et messieurs le peuple français
demain ce sera au mois que les iraniens
se battent pour leur vie et de leur
liberté
que notre armée s'opposent de manière et
je ris et or et ori théorique aux forces
supérieures de la russie
nous avons besoin d'eux
dad encore plus des deux plus de soutien
pour que la liberté ne perdent pas elle
doit être bien armé les chars les armes
antichars les avions de combat le
défenseur ayant vous pouvez nous aider
nous en avons besoin vous pouvez pour
que la liberté ne tarde pas le monde
doit le soutenir avec des sanctions
contre l'agresseur chaque semaine on ne
vont pas qu'à des sanctions
les entreprises françaises doivent
quitter le marché russe revenons au
chant leroy merlin et autres doivent
cesser d'être laisse penseur de la
machine de guerre de la russie
ils doivent arrêter de financer le
meurtre et enfants et deux femmes le
viol
tout le monde va se rappeler que les
valeurs
valent plus que des bénéfices
et nous devons déjà pensé de l'avenir de
la façon dont nous allons vivre après la
guerre il faut des garanties et des
garanties sur que la sécurité sera
inébranlable et que la guerre ne seront
plus possibles dans ce monde
donc le système de garantie au nouveau
système de qte sécurité
ou la france aura un rôle de premier
plan pour que personne
ne ferait jamais en pleurer la mort pour
que les gens vivent leur vie
et pour qu'on dise à dio pas sous les
bombes pas en état de guerre
mais quand leurs liens
avec la dignité parce que nous devons
vivre pour être respectées
pour conter guise d'au revoir
comme les français à être au revoir à
belmondo
merci la france du couloir à le prenne
présentation nationale je vous remercie
de vous être adressée aux parlementaires
monsieur au peuple français la séance
est levée
voilà pour ce discours du président
ukrainien volodimir zelensky devant les
deux chambres du parlement français le
président de l'ukraine qui a s'est
exprimé sur le drame humanitaire
actuellement en ukraine notamment à
marioupol le président ukrainien qui a
demandé également à la france de faire
preuve de leadership et qui a appelé
bien une décision historique à
l'adhésion de l'ukraine dans l'union
européenne et il a également eu des mots
très durs envers les entreprises
françaises qui continue de faire des
affaires avec la russie là notamment
cité au chant et leroy merlin il a
effectivement demandé de l'aide et un
soutien au niveau évidemment des armes
des armes antichars des avions de combat
et il a souhaité aussi que les sanctions
soient renforcés il a demandé que les
entreprises françaises puissent quitter
le marché russe des entreprises qui
aujourd'hui pour lui sponsorise la
russie et finance le meurtre d'enfants
et de femmes nicolas tenzer vous avez
entendu ces propos très fort là on a un
président ukrainien qui se bat pour
restaurer la paix pour la liberté pour
l'égalité pour la fraternité oui on a un
président qui effectivement d'un
héroïsme remarquables comme l'ensemble
du peuple ukrainien
quand on connaît un peu le peuple
ukrainien anne et moi le connaissons
on n'est pas surpris d'une certaine
manière d'abord parce que c'est un peu
vraiment européen c'est d'un meuble qui
s'est toujours battu pour l'europe sur
ce qu'a dit aussi le président hélène ce
qui me paraît aussi très important c'est
que quand on a les crimes massifs
auxquels nous avons assisté il a rappelé
au début de son intervention
n'importe quelle compromission
que ce soit pour des raisons soit disant
économique et commercial
participe du crime et je pense que leroy
merlin ono au champ total énergie et
d'autres
effectivement aide monsieur poutine
à commettre et comme l'a dit le
président et dance qui a financé les
crimes de guerre
depuis le début de la guerre
la russie a engrangé en raison
évidemment des ventes rien que
d'hydrocarbures je ne parle pas du reste
essentiellement les hydrocarbures quand
même 17 milliards d'euros 17 milliards
d'euros qui sont contenus de
l'étanchéité vous voyez entre gazprom et
d'autres grandes sociétés russes et le
budget russe qui servent à financer des
crimes de guerre
c'est la réalité simple brutale et je
crois que ce qu'a dit le président zine
ski en appelant les entreprises
françaises a quitté la russie je pense
que cet appel il doit être fait de
manière solennelle est clair par le
président de la république française
comme d'ailleurs des autres chefs d'état
et de gouvernement européens on va
prendre la suite la direction de
l'assemblée nationale et de la salle des
quatre colonnes où se trouvait la mort à
gaza elsa vous êtes aux côtés du
président de l'assemblée nationale
richard ferrand
oui a raconté nous pour vous ce symbole
ce parlement qui écoute le président et
craignant c'était très important c'était
au delà du symbole même d'abord c'était
un moment extrêmement
au vent et un moment marquant dans
l'histoire de l'assemblée nationale
puisque nous avons reçu aujourd'hui un
chef d'état en guerre nous avons compris
qu'il voulait mobiliser les opinions
publiques expliqué ce que subissent et
son pays par l'agression dont il est
victime il a également marqué de la
reconnaissance à l'action de la france
et du président de la république et nous
a demandé d'être plus actif encore à ses
côtés pour renforcer la capacité de
résistance et peuple ukrainien je vois
que à l'assemblée nationale comme au
sénat le message du président zelensky a
été reçue en profondeur et avec émotion
et conviction par tous aller plus loin
il a parlé d' adhésion à l'union
européenne il a parlé d' arme
supplémentaire de protéger le ciel
comme vous savez
c'est donc la résistance ukrainienne à
se défendre et nous continuerons à le
faire ensuite il à france 2 les pays
d'europe nous devons devenir déco
belligérants on le sait aussi quant à
l'adhésion à l'union européenne
l'ukraine a fait une démarche et il faut
que cela chemine et que les choses se
fassent un bon rythme en tout cas ces
choses là ne se font pas à lattes et
certainement pas dans le contexte
particulièrement difficile qui est
aujourd'hui celui peuple ukrainien il a
parlé longuement du désespoir des
ukrainiens en citant notamment l'exemple
de marioupol d'ukrainiens qui supplie
plaie laissée mourir phase test
désespoir que faire que dire
d'abord vous savez nous sommes comme nos
présences jeans qui si je puis dire nous
sommes évidemment tous bouleversés par
les images que vous diffusez des
informations que vous donnez je crois
que pas un français est insensible à ce
qui se passe est donc ce que nous
faisons
on le continuer et l'amplifié et le
président et vince qui a dit combien
l'action de la france d'être précieuse
aux yeux deux des ukrainiennes et des
ukrainiens qui souffrent par conséquent
nous devons rester mobilisés aux côtés
du peuple ukrainien et cela nous
confions à le faire aussi longtemps que
nécessaire il a cité la devise française
égalité liberté égalité fraternité
en disant qu'en fait cette devise elle
nous oblige aujourd'hui vis-à-vis était
pape l'ukrainien dont il a surtout dit
qu'un effet ce qui se passait en ukraine
était une manière de détruire la portée
du sens des mots que son liberté égalité
fraternité
voyons cela comme on l'appelle donné
raison merci beaucoup monsieur ferrand
président de l'assemblée nationale
merci beaucoup l on va tout de suite
heures écoutez un extrait du discours de
vladimir lisin skis devant les
parlementaires français
le président ukrainien qui revient sur
les crimes de guerre commis par la
russie notamment dans la ville de
marioupol après lehman d'invention russe
marie paule et d'autres villes
ukrainiennes frappé par l'occupant
rappelle les ruines de verdun
comme sur les photos de la première
guerre mondiale
que chacun et chacune
à vue a vu l'armée russe se ne distingue
pas les objets qu'elle cible ils
détruisent tous les quartiers
résidentiels les hôpitaux des écoles des
universités ce taux il brûlait les
entrepôts de nourriture et de
médicaments
ils prennent tout
il ne prend pas en compte les concepts
de crimes de guerre ou les obligations
sous les conventions et ils ont apporté
la terreur sur l'acheteur l'ukrainien et
chacun de vous un inconscient
annie daubenton viens d'entendre un
extrait du discours de vladimir et
l'inscrit ce drame humanitaire qui se
passe en ukraine particulièrement un
mario paul
il faut sensibiliser les opinions
publiques face à cette guerre bon je
pense qu'elles sont déjà sensibilisés
d'ailleurs le président en introduction
a dit vous êtes en france vous savez ce
qui se passe en ukraine donc il est
parfaitement conscient de cette
information qui nous habite tous il a
rajouté des éléments je dirais oui de
nature ce que l'on vient d'écouter pour
rappeler aux fonds non pas pour rappeler
de l'émotif on n'en manque pas mais pour
montrer à travers des exemples très
précis ce qui touche chaque famille et
craignait et puis l'autre chose qui m'a
semblé quand même important dans ce
désastre c'est qu'il a appelés et c'est
pas la première fois à l'élaboration
d'une nouvelle architecture
sécuritaire alors bon avec habileté il
dit où la france aurait toute sa place
pour reprendre le rôle d'un rôle leader
mais c'est vrai que il a déjà eu
plusieurs initiatives dans ce domaine il
avait énoncé je crois il ya quelques
jours trois quatre jours une initiative
qui s'appelait eu 24 qui était l'idée
que unies pour la paix en 24 heures
c'est à dire le pays a été tellement
dévasté par la rapidité cette invasion
qui l'a si je puis dire que tout le pays
a dans la chair cette urgence terrible
que c'est très rapidement que l'on
pouvait arrêter le processus est que
plus on attend effectivement
plus plus les choses deviennent
dramatiques et ce qui était habile dans
cette proposition qu'il a faite citant
thèse peu importe
c'était 2
de mettre dans le même dans cette même
unité d'urgence les épidémies les
guerres et les désastres naturels et
parce que quand même c'est le pays de
tchernobyl il faut bien comprendre et
donc j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait là
quelque chose de d'une sorte d'
inventions du futur qui n'est sûrement
pas à reprendre au pied de la lettre la
question n'est pas là mais qui pouvait
être de sa part finalement une avancée
intéressante on va évoquer dans la
partie la géopolitique de son discours
puisqu'il a cité notamment le format
normandie au début du conflit les
premières années du conflit avec ce
dialogue entre français et allemands et
ukrainiens et russes je voudrais d'abord
qu'on reste sur cette partie ce drame
humanitaire qui est fait le début du
discours de volodymyr zelensky face aux
parlementaires français et cette ville
de marioupol dont le design ce qu'il a
dit vladimir poutine bombardent sans
distinction quel est l'objectif avec
mario paul dupré en russe quel était
l'objectif est que grosse ni en 99 2000
ou alep homs en syrie vous savez quand
on conduit on a quelqu'un qui ait résolu
à mener ce que je n'hésite pas de nommer
en l'occurrence à mario paul une guerre
d'extermination
il s'agit de tuer tout ce qui bouge
d'exterminer
et ceux qui seraient survivants de les
tuer ou comme on commence à le voir
maintenant elle est déportée
et déportés y'a pas d'autres mots comme
staline l'avait fait pour les tatars de
crimée vers la réussit même
maintenant comment ça à connaître un
certain nombre d'habitants donc on n'est
plus dans des objectifs de guerre en
classique prendre un territoire
on est dans une stratégie volontaire de
terreur mais encore une fois
nous qui a version depuis 10 ans 15 ans
voire 20 ans
on n'a pas écouté on n'a pas compris
aussi ce que ces crimes massifs à
marioupol wire kharkiv aussi il
m'appelle marie gopaul encore pire
disait de la nature du régime russe
quand vous avez un régime qui est fondée
sur le crime je rappellerai quand même
ça a été très bien démontré dans le
livre extraordinaire n'est pas traduit
en français malheureusement de catherine
belton twins people les gens ont
peut-être quand vous savez que monsieur
poutine a commencé sa carrière non
seulement on le sait comme agent du kgb
hadès 13 mai avec près semblablement une
aide au mouvement terroriste allemand la
route armée fraktion la bande à baader
que ensuite lorsqu'il était à saint
pétersbourg il a composé c'était
démontré avec les syndicats du crime
locaux à saint pétersbourg on a
quelqu'un qui a encore une fois cette
stratégie qui a toujours été dans ce te
dans ce crime et donc ce que l'on ne
voit à marioupol ce n'est jamais que la
continuité de cela il ya eu la prese de
la crimée il ya eu le don de basse on
voyait clair dans la stratégie de la
voyait parfaitement clair et encore une
fois nous étions quelques-uns mois en
france d'autres dans d'autres pays à
l'étranger à a alerté et à mettre en
garde contre aussi tout ce stratégie de
reset comme monsieur obama en 2009 je me
souviens j'étais aux états unis en 2008
j'en ai beaucoup discuté mais j'ai dit
aux as des amis américains n'ont pas
grisolles quand vous avez eu emmanuel
macron pensait bien faire certainement
mais qu'il a parlé d'une stratégie vous
avez dû nationalité de sécurité et de
confiance le terme confiance trust
en quoi peut il s'appliquer un régime de
cette nature la plus de sens aujourd'hui
avec la recette et il n'y avait jamais
eu de sens mais aujourd'hui on le voit
on va on va continuer les réactions des
parlementaires à ce discours du
président ukrainien on va aller en salle
des conférences du sénat retrouver quand
un call mais quand on vous êtes avec
bruno retailleau le président du groupe
l'est républicain du sénat tout à fait
bon jour bruno retailleau que retenez
vous de ces treize minutes très
solennelle d'un message diffusé dans les
deux chambres du parlement avec cette
comparaison avec les ruines de verdun
cet effort comme moment qu'est ce que
vous en retenez pas ce que j'en retiens
c'est quand même c'est la première fois
et c'est historique c'est inédit que
nous avons un chef d'état d'un pays en
guerre directement et simultanément à
partir du sénat et puis de l'assemblée
nationale vous avez vu est ce qui était
très émouvant aussi c'est qu'il a choisi
comme il avait fait d'ailleurs devant
d'autres parlements je pense au
parlement allemand le parlement
britannique il a cité un certain nombre
d'image de référence qui nous touche
directement les ruines de verdun j'ai un
grand père moi qui a fait la guerre 14
18 il a cité aussi la liberté l'égalité
la fraternité la devise républicaine
c'était donc très touchant et on se
sentait vraiment totalement impliqué oui
il a aussi et bien dit que toutes les
cartes étaient entre nos mains pour
restaurer la paix cela signifie qu'il ya
aujourd'hui des choses que la france
peut faire doit faire ça vous avez
compris aussi exactement j'ai retenu une
phrase qui est une phrase clé qui est
importante et il a dit nos valeurs
communes valent mieux que nous bénéfices
il a voulu dire que on soutient des
valeurs ses valeurs de liberté de
souveraineté pour un peuple égalité d'un
peuple pour nous qui vont infliger des
sanctions on va avoir un effet boomerang
qu'on l'a déjà sur l'inflation mais que
c'est une autre forme de guerre et qu'on
doit il prendre notre part et toute
notre part mais volodymyr inscrit des
esclaves ou pour les entreprises
françaises qui sont toujours sur le sol
de russie il les a appelés à quitter le
sol de russie car eh bien elles sont la
machine de guerre de la russie at il dit
cela qu'ensuite il a fait une référence
à à nos valeurs plus fortes que nos
bénéfices vous êtes d'accord il faut que
toutes les entreprises françaises auchan
renault leroy merlin équipe maintenant
la russie ce sont les russes qui a cité
écoutez je veux pas faire de cas sur
telle ou telle entreprise je pense qu'il
faut faire attention d'ailleurs
j'observe que total energy a bougé
depuis hier soir parce qu'il ya des
décisions qui ont été importantes mais
nous pour ce qui nous concerne hommes
femmes politiques et je vais dans
quelques instants à matignon pour une
union de liaison exactement nous devons
fournir un une aide qui tu n'aides avec
des armes bien sûr pour aider ce peuple
et rock héroïque à pouvoir se battre et
nous devons aider aussi sur le plan
humanitaire il y a les réfugiés mais il
ya aussi le plan humanitaire parce qu'on
voit bien que les russes sont en train
de pousser une partie de la population
ukrainienne à la famine on l'a entendu
assez le fait qu'ils voient là disait
que le présent de macron faisait preuve
d'un véritable leadership
là dessus il a salué l'action des menus
et le maquereau vous l'avez entendu ces
passionnés mais bien sûr il a à chaque
fois d'ailleurs et pour chaque parlement
ce qui est naturel il a encouragé chaque
chaque chef d'état chef domestique mais
c'est normal parce que nous sommes sont
alliés et c'est normal et lui si vous
voulez son alter ego en france bien
entendu c'était mal m'accroche je
regrette moi c'est que cette diplomatie
l'aï eu finalement peu de résultats mais
qu'importe je pense qu'il faut qu'on
soit uni et il faut que la france
s'affirme au côté de ce peuple est un
peuple courage qui est un très grand
peuple et qui nous montre que pour
gagner une guerre il ya les armes il ya
aussi la volonté la question de la
souveraineté nationale c'est une
question la volonté d'un peuple et merci
bruno retailleau et donc comme tous les
chefs de file des différents groupes
politiques du sénat vous quittez le
sénat l'a tout de suite pour rejoindre
matignon avec ce comité de liaison sur
l'ukraine à matino merci quand un calme
et on prend tout eu de la direction de
l'assemblée nationale la salle des
quatre colonnes l amont d'un gars va
vous êtes avec nicolas dupont aignan il
est un président du groupe u10 à
l'assemblée nationale mais il est aussi
candidat à la présidentielle
exactement et vous avez un discours un
petit peu différent vous qu'avez vous
pensé de l'intervention de volodymyr
zelensky une intervention émouvante
parce que ce qui se passe en ukraine est
une tragédie pour les ukrainiens
maintenant en fait monsieur zielinski
dans son rôle il va entraîner la france
dans la guerre
et moi j'estime que la france ne doit
pas envoyer des combattants là bas voilà
et je pense ce que j'ai regretté dans ce
discours c'est qu'à aucun moment
les contours d'une offre de paix c'est à
dire comment monsieur ellis qui voit la
suite du conflit il veut nous entraîner
dans la guerre et c'est normal de son
point de vue mais qu'est ce qu'ils
proposent pour après et c'est ça que
j'ai été un peu déçu c'est que en vérité
il n'y a pas derrière l'offre l'idée de
l'ukraine après et je crois que
l'urgence si on veut sauver des vies
notamment des ukrainiens c'est bien
évidemment de proposer un plan de paix
est que j'ai fait sauf que le cren le
président et craignant pourrait dire la
paix il suffit que la en russie arrête
la guerre finalement ça c'est la pallice
c'est pas le cas oui dont il a dit la
dre comme si on est paré société sur le
même plan on se re ya deux parties on a
unique et agresseurs l'autre est
agressée il reste que monsieur henné ski
par exemple refusent l'idée d'un
l'ukraine neutre
or je crois que c'est la seule solution
l'autriche est neutre cuba était neutre
quand les russes ont voulu mettre des
missiles il ya eu un compromis où il
faut que l'ukraine fait des concessions
même si finalement elle est pour rien
n'y sera pour rien mais à la fin vous
verrez est ce qu'il faut attendre qu'ils
aient cent mille morts 20 millions de
personnes des ménages et d'ukraine pour
arriver à ce qu'on aurait pu faire au
départ la paix vous savez c'est toujours
fait par des compromis
ou alors la victoire totale de l'un sur
l'autre donc moi je vous le dis si on
est franc si on a un cerveau autant
qu'un coeur et si au contraire on veut
sauver des vies il ya urgence à avoir
une conférence sur la sécurité en europe
et à définir les pays qui seront dans le
temps ceux qui n'y seront pas de manière
à avoir la paix donc la paix ça exige un
compromis donc là si vous pouviez
répondre à volodimir zelensky y vous lui
auriez dit bon c'est quoi les gens mais
finalement il faut aussi un phare de
croissance
pourquoi vous oui parce que
malheureusement le cren n'a pas respecté
les accords de minsk personne ne le dit
mais c'est la vérité les russes non plus
mais les torts ont été partagés au
départ maintenant la faute est
complètement du côté russe moi je veux
le que les troupes russes se retire je
veux qu'on arrête les atrocités et je
veux qu'on revienne à une architecture
européenne de paix et je veux dire aux
français qu a que deux solutions soit
l'engagement dans la guerre totale soit
une offre de paix mais la solution
intermédiaire n'existe pas c'est envoyer
aux martyrs des millions d'ukrainiens
mais je n'aime pas la manière dont on le
fait en ce moment merci beaucoup nicolas
dupont aignan l'a senti un discours bien
différent de la sorte d'union nationale
qui est ici à l'assemblée nationale
merci beaucoup et les amendes à gaza
direction la salle des conférences du
sénat pour une autre réaction d'un
président de groupe politique au sénat
le président claude malhuret la prison
du groupe les indépendants oui
effectivement un claude malhuret qui ici
le président du couple indépendant
répliqué territoire bonjour monsieur
murray on voit à l'assemblée nationale
il a une particularité il y a trois
députés qui sont également candidats à
l'élection présidentielle marine le pen
jean-luc mélenchon et nicolas dupont
aignan que l'on vient d'entendre on a pu
les suspecté d'avoir des dépositions qui
était comme ça jugé pro russe qu'est ce
que vous pensez de leur position
aujourd'hui quand on voit cette union
nationale du parlement et des députés
qui semble voilà dire qu'il faut
remettre en cause un petit peu comme
cela la position de l'ukraine notamment
sur l'europe écoutez ça fait des années
que ces trois personnes et un certain
nombre d'autres sont les caniches de
poutine n'y a pas d'autre mot et depuis
le début de la guerre les uns sont
devenus les paillassons ce sont les
seuls qui ne condamnent pas fermement à
l'invasion ce sont les seuls qui essaye
de faire en sorte qu' on est par
l'ukraine qu'on n'en voit pas d'armes à
l'ukraine que l'on ne prenne pas de
sanction ce sont les seuls à jouer le
jeu de poutine encore en prenant la
neutralité blues de l'ukraine et la
situation telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui
la la la la diction de la crimée
confirmé l'annexion du donbass il
continue bien sommes bien sûr ils sont
obligés de comptes a donné l'impression
parce que tout le monde l'a condamné de
condamner les horreurs et les atrocités
mais ils n'ont pas changé d'un poil ce
sont c'était les caniches de poutine ils
en sont devenus les paillassons et
aujourd'hui ils en sont les complices
claude malhuret qu'est ce que vous
retenez dès treize minutes que l'on a
entendu être tout à l'heure dans
l'hémicycle volodymyr aînés ski qui
appelle à faire pression ensemble sur la
russie à se battre pour notre liberté
commune c'était un moment intense
impressionnant évidemment c'est un
moment de très grande émotion de voir en
direct sur sept sur sept grands ce grand
écran le président ukrainien un moment
d'émotion partagée par tous debout
applaudissant aussi bien à l'assemblée
nationale qu'au sénat
c'est la première chose qu'on retient de
cette qu'on retiendra de cet après midi
mais l'autre chose évidence et l'appel
du président aulas qui l'appelle à
augmenter les sanctions et non pas à les
diminuer n'ont pas hésité c'est l'appel
à l'aide pour se défendre contre la
russie c'est l'appel aux valeurs
européennes il insisté dessus moi je
retiens un mot de ceux de son discours
par particulièrement les valeurs valent
plus que les bénéfices voilà ça ça m'a
frappé c'est exactement ce qu'il faut
que nous nous disions aujourd'hui en
france et encore une fois il a pris cet
exemple parler des entreprises
françaises qui sont encore présentes en
russie il en a cité plusieurs dont
auchan notamment laura merling il les
appelle et bien quitter le sol de la
russie
sinon elles sont les machines de guerre
de la russie vous êtes d'accord avec
cela il faut maintenant que ces groupes
revient en france il faut que le
augmentions les sanctions il faut
j'espère que demain et demain il ya
beaucoup de réunions fondamentale l'otan
avec joe biden les réunions au niveau de
l'union européenne il est essentiel de
poursuivre l'effort il est surtout
essentiel de l'augmenter s'il ya une
seule chose que l'on peut obtenir de
l'intervention 2 et lens qui aujourd'hui
c'est son appel désespéré à aller plus
loin je vais dire une dernière
permettait j'avais dit au début de
l'invasion que cette invasion serait le
premier clou sur le cercueil de la
dictature de poutine comme l'invasion de
l'afghanistan avait été le premier clou
sur le cercueil de l'union soviétique
petit à petit on est en train de
s'apercevoir que c'est ce qui est en
train de se passer bien entendu il faut
y participer et il faut favoriser cette
issue merci claude malhuret pour votre
message au micro de public sénat merci
quand un calme mais nous sommes aussi à
l'assemblée nationale salle des quatre
colonnes où se trouvait la mondah
gavalda vous êtes avec jean christophe
lagarde qui est président du computer i
à l'assemblée oui qui doit se rendre
aussi à matignon pour le comité de
liaison parlementaire qu'avez vous pensé
de cette adresse est très émouvante
volodymyr zelensky a insisté sur
l'inhumanité le désespoir de son peuple
d'abord c'est en fin d'assemblée
nationale pour ma part la séance la plus
émouvante
kelly m'était donné d'assister parce que
volodymyr elias qui est en train
d'illustrer ce que peut représenter un
peuple qui se bat jusqu'à la mort qui
paye par le sang le prix de la liberté
on a totalement oublié ça dans nos pays
on parle souvent de la liberté dans cet
hémicycle lui il est en train avec son
peuple dans pays le véritable prix
deuxièmement parce que il nous dit j'ai
besoin de vous j'ai besoin de vous
parlementaires français gouvernement
français peuple français il a besoin
d'armes il a besoin d'argent comme toute
nation en guerre il a aussi besoin de
notre générosité nos solidarités dans
l'accueil de réfugiés de celles et ceux
qui ne peuvent pas se battre et dont les
maris et les pères sont en train de se
battre contre l'agression russe et puis
il décrit évidemment le drame qu'est
cette bière ou les russes massac
détruisent des villes entières
et naturellement on ne peut que compatir
à ce qui se passe et c'était espérer que
ça s'arrête le plus vite possible mais
vous savez la meilleure façon d'arrêter
une guerre c'est de faire en sorte que
le foot il tire la conclusion qui ne
peut pas gagner pour ça il a besoin
d'armes et l'argent je vous fait réagir
à ce que disait nicolas dupont aignan il
ya quelques minutes à d'autres micros il
dit mais en fait volodymyr nm ce qu'il
veut nous attirer dans la guerre il veut
qu'on fasse la guerre qu'on devienne
déco belligérants pour vous on peut
rester dans les sanctions sont s'engager
davantage militairement je pense que
nicolas dupont aignan a mal entendu ce
qu'a dit le président c'est ce qui l'a
pas demandée par exemple qu'on aille
faire la guerre aux avions russes on
souhaite pas le faire ça déclencherait
une troisième guerre mondiale il ya
d'autres façons de gagner cette bataille
les combattants ukrainiens sont en train
de le montrer malgré tout l'armada russe
malgré leur infériorité numérique
merdeux malgré le recteur you it et en
blindés etc ils ont réussi à empêcher
les russes de prendre pied et bien
d'autres villes donc il ya d'autres
façons de gagner une guerre par l'usure
en l'occurrence des russes qui ne sont
plus très loin du point où une pompe
l'attaqué ça c'est la première chose et
puis la deuxième chose il a demandé qu'
une décision soit prise d'adhésion à
l'union européenne il a renoncé à
l'adhésion à l'otan c'est-à-dire
comprends que ça serait impossible de
trouver une voie de sortie avec vladimir
poutine par contre il demande d'adhésion
à l'union européenne et l'union
européenne c'est une union aujourd'hui
économique et ce peuple est en train de
payer par le prix du sang l'attachement
à nos valeurs l'espoir qu'ils ont de
vivre demain comme nous je dis oui il
faut ouvrir ces négociations elles
seront longues par nature parce qu'on
parle d'économie de choses complexes
mais il faut lancer au peuple ukrainien
et j'appelle le président bak rond à le
faire il faut lancer au peuple ukrainien
ce geste d'espoir vous faites partie de
la famille européenne vous partagez ces
valeurs vous êtes en train de combattre
pour ses valeurs par quoi alors que nous
sommes même plus en mesure de le faire
ou capable de le faire
vous faites partie de la famille
européenne venez nous rejoindre vous
vous battez depuis si longtemps pour sa
démocratiquement et maintenant
malheureusement militairement merci
beaucoup je le disais vous allez
rejoindre jean castex à matignon est ce
qu'il ya un comité de liaison des
différents présidents des groupes
parlementaires pour se tenir informé sur
la situation crée diable merci beaucoup
elsa on continue à analyser ce discours
du président ukrainien devant le
parlement français en plateau avec mes
invités on va justement évoqué les
attentes de volodymyr zelensky vis-à-vis
des européens il lance notamment un
appel à l'adhésion de l'ukraine à
l'union européenne on va l'écouter
demain ce sera au mois que les
ukrainiens se battent pour leur vie et
de leur liberté
que notre armée se pose de manière et
jori et théoriques euros rythme aux
forces supérieures de la russie
nous avons besoin d'eux dad encore plus
des deux plus de soutien pour que la
liberté ne parle pas elle doit être bien
armé les chars les jardins anti chars
les avions de combat le défenseur ayant
vous pouvez nous aider nous en avons
besoin vous pouvez pour que la liberté
ne part de pas le monde doit le soutenir
avec des sanctions contre l'agresseur
alors nicolas tenzer est ce que le
président et l'inscrit peut être entendu
sur l'adhésion de l'ukraine à l'union
européenne il doit l'être il doit l'être
personnellement ça fait huit ans que je
demande que la voie de l'adhésion à
l'union européenne soit tracée pour
l'ukraine parce que ça fait huit ans pas
seulement depuis le 24 février mais ça
fait huit ans que l'ukraine se bat au
l'europe dans cette guerre que ni les
américains ni les européens ne veulent
faire c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui disons
les vrais combattants de l'europe ce
sont les soldats et les volontaires et
ukrainiens là aussi depuis huit ans
quatorze mille morts avant même le début
de cette nouvelle offensive de poutine
quatorze mille morts 1,6 million de
déplacés je rappellerai la révolution de
maidan qui se fait au nom des valeurs
européennes et contre l'avis de
ianoukovitch l'ancien président
il a été chassé par cette révolution qui
avait trahi ses engagements et refusez
vous savez l'accord d'association avec
l'union européenne et donc aujourd'hui
encore une fois je crois que l'adhésion
il faut absolument la dea il faut le
faire de manière accélérée alors pas
demain personne ne considère que
l'ukraine peu pour
moi je pense qu'à une échéance de 4,5
ans ce qui serait déjà un rythme
accéléré par rapport au précédent de
procédure d'adhésion pour les anciens
pays d'europe centrale et orientale qui
ait des membres de l'espace je dirais
pas soviétique comme on dit c'est déjà
beaucoup mais je pense qu'il faut
vraiment accéléré tout cela la culture
effectivement de l'otan jeu poche je
voudrais juste dire une seule chose
imaginons que en 2008 alors qu'il y
avait eu cette résistance de la france
et de l'allemagne au sommet de bucarest
que l'ukraine et était membre de l'otan
collier à tour des ce qu'on appelle une
map un schème est moche cacho plane un
plan pour l'adhésion à l'otan il est
probable que ce qui s'est passé en 2014
c'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
n'aurait pas eu lieu
annie daubenton cette adhésion de
l'ukraine à l'union européenne et
pourquoi pas à l'otan selon vous c'est
une solution ou est-ce que ça peut être
un motif d' escalade de l'affrontement
entre la russie et l'occident en tout
cas je suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce
qui vient d'être dit c'est vrai qu'on a
raté un cap terrible en 2008 et que ça a
permis cette horreur de se passer alors
maintenant quelle serait la solution ou
savez bien sûr il faut une adhésion
accélérée c'est tout à fait évident
c'était tout à fait la
marche de l'ukraine s'est année dernière
c'est-à-dire tout était arrimé aussi
bien d'ailleurs sur le plan militaire
que sur le plan des réformes
sociales dérives de toutes les réformes
possibles étaient vraiment dans
l'optique de cet arrimage
à l'union européenne
là aussi les choses ont trop tardé
maintenant c'est très difficile de se
dire qu'on va accélérer au moment où ce
pays est démolie complètement et qu'on
le se demande jusqu'où on va aller et
comment on va le récupérer donc là bien
sûr qu'il ya cette énergie magnifique
que les ukrainiens montre mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
points d'interrogation à l'horizon
l'urgentiste ims et d'arrêter le conflit
le plus vite possible après les
questions géopolitiques d'adhésion
sécuritaires sont bien sûr seront
absolument nécessaire et les bienvenus
alors vous l'avez dit et l'un et l'autre
les discussions existent depuis
plusieurs années maintenant entre la
france l'allemagne l'ukraine et la
russie pour trouver des solutions à ce
conflit et notamment ce format normandie
qui a été évoqué par le président s'est
inscrit tout à l'heure dans le par au
parlement
président il y avait déjà en format pour
les négociations avec la fédération de
la russie c'était un format normandie le
format des négociations qui devraient
mettre fin à la guerre dans les zones
basses la guerre à l'est de l'ukraine et
qui dure depuis huit ans malheureusement
quelqu'un le soutenions et quelqu'un a
essayé de retarder le processus et ils
voulaient le perturber mais il semblait
important que le monde soit toujours à
cette table normandie
et quand il y avait des résultats des
négociations quand nous avons réussi à
libérer les gens de la captivité quand
nous avons pu négocier certaines
décisions en 2019 c'était une bouffée
d'air frais comme une leur d'espoir
l'espoir que le conversation avec le
russie peuvent était que les dirigeants
de l'ère ici peuvent être persuadé par
les paroles que nous secoue de choisir
la paix nicolas tenzer c'est intéressant
ce que dit
sur ce format normandie dans ce dialogue
qui avaient été noués entre français et
allemands ukrainiens et russes puisque
demain et bien volodymyr à nice qui va
s'adresser à double il est présent à
bruxelles pour le sommet de l'otan
notamment pour le g7 et le conseil
européens quel est le bon interlocuteur
dans ce conflit est ce que ce sont les
européens ou les américains pour
dialoguer avec la russie je pense que ce
sont les deux je pense qu'on a besoin
que des deux ça a été dit à un moment
dans le débat tout à l'heure de tout
simplement sur le plan de la sécurité
nous savons très bien que sans les
américains nous ne pourrons tout seul
rien faire pas nous européens chantant
peut-être qu'avec qui vont nous pouvons
en humus clé dans les 20 années qui
viennent mais avant 20 ans je ne vois
pas malheureusement l'europe seule
intervenir
sans les états unis ça c'est la première
chose dans la discussion ça veut dire
aussi que ça des conséquences
aujourd'hui soyons parfaitement clair
les discussions avec la russie s'est
terminée toute négociation aujourd'hui
avec ce régime serait un jour d'un jeu
de dupes parce que il permettrait à ce
régime d'être normalisée d'une certaine
manière il ne peut pas y avoir de
normalisation qu'en tout cas forman
normandie je voudrais quand même
rappeler une chose pourquoi est ce que
la chancelière merkel et le président
hollande ont lancé c'est une discussion
de normandie c'était précisément aussi
parce que les états unis avaient décidé
des chats en 2014 de ne pas intervenir
en ukraine est donc devant les massacres
terrible qui avait été déjà commis par
l'armée russe ce conflit terrible encore
une fois je rappel quatorze mille
victimes bien le président français la
chancelière allemande ont dit mais
essayons de trouver quelque chose pour
stopper ce conflit et donc ça a mené
l'ukraine à faire un certain nombre de
compromis
c'était président prochaine qu à
l'époque président de l'ukraine qui les
avait fait et il ne pouvait pas faire
autrement mais après qu'est ce qui s'est
passé dans puis depuis toutes ces années
c'est tout simplement que la russie a
refusé concrètement d'appliquer les
accords de minsk notamment sur le
désengagement des troupes il était prévu
par exemple des élections ni plus
d'autonomie
décentralisation pour les régions
notamment du dôme bascou
et tout à l'heure
excusez moi ça c'est monsieur
dupont-aignan vous comprendrez je
reprendrai volonté les formules de
claude malhuret à son égard quand on est
à ce point je le dirai à prendre
l'expression américaine par ben au lit
avec la russie à ce point complices de
ce régime criminel depuis si longtemps
je dirais qu'il faudrait mieux ne pas
rajouter le mensonge à la dignité
année daubenton nicolas tenzer dit à
l'instant on ne peut plus discuter
aujourd'hui avec le régime de vladimir
poutine comment on négocie la paix
aujourd'hui au niveau international
n'ont su plus possible c'est même
impensable
comment négocier
vous savez c'est dramatique parce qu'il
ya des négociations quotidienne en
ukraine avec les délégations russe et
ukrainienne et on voit que l'on n'avance
pas d'un millimètre et que tout ce
qu'ils essayent d'obtenir de ces
négociations c'est de gagner du temps
gagner du temps pour continuer cette ses
crimes sur place donc malheureusement
oui il y a il ya pour l'instant pas
d'interlocuteur au kremlin y en at il
d'autres en russie je ne sais pas
l'avenir le dira peut-être on peut
l'espérer mais pour l'instant au kremlin
non il n'y a plus de possibilités on va
repartir à l'assemblée nationale où se
trouvaient les amours d'un gab à salle
des quatre colonnes est là vous êtes
avec olivier faure qui est député
socialiste de seine et marne et qui est
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste
que répondre à volodimir zelensky qui
rappelle la devise française liberté
égalité fraternité qui nous demande de
mettre nos valeurs avant les profits
pour vous quelle est la réponse
politique diplomatique ou militaire à
apporter
alors ces paroles fortes du président
hélène ci doivent être entendus il s'est
exprimé en notre direction mais aussi en
question toutes les françaises et tous
les français et il dit livraison des
armes pour qu'on puisse se défendre et
c'est à vous d'en décider c'est à eux de
décider de la guerre et de la paix c'est
lui qui sont agressés et nous dit aussi
il ya des gens aujourd'hui qui alimente
le géant russe parce qu'ils continuent à
commercer avec lui des grandes enseignes
qui continue total auchan leroy merlin
pour ne citer qu'elles qu'ils continuent
quand elle c'est la russie donc qui
chaque jour en voie d euros en fait au
logis en russe et donc ce qu'il faut sur
quoi il faut répondre le gouvernement
devrait d'abord avoir une action directe
en question de ses enseignes et s'il ne
le faisait pas et si ses autres
enseignes n'obtempérait pas bien moi ce
que je crois c'est que nous devons nous
appeler au boycott des produits vendus
par ces enseignes aulas à leur dire
écoutez si vous pensez que vous allez
continuer à faire plus d'argent en
continuant avec la russie présenterait
moins en france parce que c'est comme ça
que vous ne peut pas brader nos valeurs
fait pourquoi nous nous battons pour ses
valeurs pour lesquelles des gens meurent
aujourd'hui en ukraine vous pouvez pour
quelques paniers de dollars
supplémentaires continué à tout brader
voilà il ya des choses qui ne se font
pas boycott des enseignes françaises qui
travaillent encore avec la russie
boycotte aussi sur le gaz le pétrole
russe mais il faudra payer l'énergie
plus cher ou avoir un peu plus froid
l'hiver prochain il faut que les fonds
c'est soit prêt à faire ces sacrifices
il faut effectivement se dire que ce qui
se passe en ukraine n'est peut-être que
la préfiguration de ce qui peut se
passer plus loin encore personne mais
adepte de la ligne à poutine et personne
ne sait quelles sont ses intentions
réelles et ses buts de guerre tout le
monde à tous ceux qui le prenait pour un
gentil drôle un gentil garçon se sont
bien trompés et se sont bien rendus
compte qu'en vérité il était en fait
l'offre que tout le monde avait décrit
et donc nous devons effectivement être
parfaitement solidaires du peuple
ukrainien c'est pas possible de laisser
un peuple européen là à notre frontière
et leur dire écoutez votre sort ne nous
intéresse plus on s'est habitué à vos
morts est donc maintenant photo merci
beaucoup olivier faure et comme vous
l'avez dit au président ukrainien bien
dit qu'il s'adressait pas seulement aux
parlementaires mais bien au peuple
français merci et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci nicolas tenzer merci
annie daubenton d'avoir été avec nous
cet après-midi merci à l'excellent et
merci à vous tous de nous avoir suivi un
moment historique donc devant lé
parlement français l'assemblée nationale
le sénat ouvre le dit me raser l'ins qui
a demandé l'adhésion de l'ukraine à
l'union européenne ait davantage de
sanctions contre la russie voilà les
temps forts de cette intervention du
président ukrainien merci à vous tous
donc de nous avoir suivis et très bonne
suite de programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires
[Musique]
pourvu que ça dure c'est l'émission qui
rend les co-responsables cette semaine
on vous parle d'immobilier durable car
le bâtiment est aujourd'hui l'un des
secteurs les plus polluants mais la
donne est en train de changer avec une
réglementation plus contraignante
notamment dans l'ancien le marché du
neuf qui est également en train de faire
sa révolution on en parlera avec
véronique b d'agde la dg de nexity
pourvu que ça dure aujourd'hui à 16h30
sur public sénat
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous
bienvenue dans ce sens public j'ai le
bonheur de vous donner rendez-vous tous
les jours pour 90 minutes de débat
d'actualité de réflexion notre promesse
et de donner du sens à l'actualité et
donner des clés de compréhension aux
citoyens sens publiques présenté par
thomas hugues du lundi au jeudi à 18
heures et à 22 heures sur public sénat
[Musique]
c'était le 2 décembre 2020 ou vers 16h50
17 heures donc en plein hiver fin de
journée
c'était encore en confinement et morgane
était aller couper du bois dans ce
bosquet ici qui se trouve à une centaine
de mètres de sa maison
il avait un casque orange une
tronçonneuse est en fait à
l'entour 16h50 17 heures il ya un
chasseur qui l'a pris pour un sanglier
et qu'il a qui attire et qui l'a touché
au thorax
il a été il ya eu une tentative de
réanimation
et
mais au final il est décédé quelques
minutes après
le lendemain il ya le procureur du lot
qui a dit que toutes les règles de
sécurité avaient été respectées
du coup on s'est dit mais comment
comment il peut y avoir
le hamas hasina du d'un homme alors que
des règles de sécurité ont été
respectées ça veut dire que les règles
ne sont pas du tout suffisante il ya
quand même une différence de taille
entre assemblée et un homme debout au
thorax
c'est c'est ça en fait on comprend pas
comment à partir de quel point un
chasseur peut confondre un humain d'un
mètre 90 avec un sanglier
donc
merci à tous et à tout ceux d'être là ça
me fait plaisir de vous voir et je sais
que ça aurait fait pas plaisir à morgane
aussi
bien sûr on n'a pas oublié les
circonstances dans laquelle il est mort
tué dans son jardin à 25 ans à cause du
soi-disant loisirs de certains
nous avons pas oublié le choc prend pas
oublier l'horreur
ni la compréhension de ce moment nous
n'avons pas oublié
et nous ne l'avons pas pardonné
c'est un ami un quelqu'un qui a vu
grandir je pense qu'il faut réguler ça
en tout cas ces rapports qu'on a avec la
chasse parce que mon habitants campagne
on a peur en fait enfin moi j'ai une
fille on a peur de se balader quoi je
trouve que la chasse prendre trop de
trop de place dans les campagnes moi je
vis à la campagne
et quand on se promène je suis trop
c'est pour moi c'est une agression
moi c'est audrey à côté de moi y'a zoo
on représente le collectif un jour un
chat ça nous avons mis en ligne sur le
site du sénat une pétition
pour que le sénat écoute nos demandes
donc nous demandons le mercredi et le
dimanche sans chasse un renforcement des
distances de sécurité par rapport aux
habitations
vingt trois jours il y a les seins et
1001 qui sont donc les autres car sein
du collectif avec nous les villas sont
auditionnés au sénat pour ouvrir donc la
mission control qui a été ouverte par le
sénat sincèrement que morgane est mort
et parvient à nantes pour continuer
lâche rien on est sur la première marche
et on va continuer voilà merci à 12
[Musique]
non
non je pense qu'à de rares sont ceux
tels que world léa et 1001 deux amis
d'enfance de morgane keane se rejoignent
à paris elles vivent maintenant l
étranger mais reste active dans le
collectif créé après sa mort en fait
c'est quelque chose qu'on va distribuer
aux sénateurs qui seront présents et qui
rassemble les textes qu'on a et fait
donc les différentes tribunes la
pétition et le communauté qu'on a fait
quand le sénat sans message est en gros
donc quelques heures elles seront
auditionnés au sénat une chambre l image
plutôt pro chasse
bien non natation ok alors le 2 décembre
2020 en plein confinement notre ami
d'enfance et voisins morgan keane a été
abattu par un chasseur qui l'aurait
confondu avec un sanglier alors qu'il
coupait du bois dans son jardin avec une
tronçonneuse je pense que tu peux parler
un peu plus fluide devrait
très vite nous avons pris conscience
après la mort de leur ami les soutiens
et témoignages ont afflué de toute la
france